I want to let you know that we have a
second show added in Atlanta Georgia
that's on April 5th that's right we also
have uh shows at Amherst and Brisbane in
the Australia all those are available
now theovon
docomo and only get tickets through
theo.
comom if tickets are overpriced uh via a
second site or something don't buy them
from scalpers just wait we'll come back
around sometime um yeah that's the best
way to do it and thank you guys for the
support and if we're not coming to your
city or country yet then just give it
time we will do our best and uh we love
you guys and thank you so much for the
support amen today's guest is a
professional pitcher for more than 10
years in Major League Baseball um he was
the winner of the golden spikes award in
college for the best collegiate baseball
player of the year um he's won the Sai
Young he's been an Allstar uh he's
recently played in Japan because of some
interesting
circumstances um I'm really grateful to
learn about what the past few years of
his life have been like and to get to
know him today's guest is Mr Trevor
Bower
[Music]
me I'll sit and tell you my
stories
shine on
me and I will find a song I
[Applause]
sing these are
sm7 sm7 yeah okay I know these
mics yeah you know a lot about this this
uh these stuff you know more than I do
okay yeah I got into photography back in
2017 started learning about it and then
started the media company momentum in
2019 so I had to you know Buy cameras
and lenses and figure all the stuff out
so I learned about it your tripods are
in a lot nicer condition than ours we
put them in the cage where like
baseballs are flying so the legs are all
bent and broken oh
yeah um yeah thanks dude yeah I I could
probably learn from I could literally
probably go watch uh one of your YouTube
videos and learn more about our own
equipment so maybe I should do that um
do you like to know everything about
stuff kind of like
like well I guess if you're starting
your own Media company if you because
you have your own YouTube channel yeah
yeah you like it it's good I enjoy it um
started it to try to entertain Baseball
fans um so that's what we try to do I
think we do a pretty good job we can do
better always trying to get better but
yeah it's fun that's what I enjoy doing
so yeah going to work every day and try
to make some some sort of fun content to
entertain people yeah I saw some videos
on there you were having fun with some
of the Japanese players because yeah
yeah yeah they were uh it's it's kind of
interesting because they don't speak the
same language so the same the type of
you know banter back and forth that you
normally have you can't really have so
the banter becomes a little bit more
like body language and facial expression
so it was a challenge to like get that
but it's also fun you know it's like a
new experience and like baseball is kind
of a universal language so they kind of
understood and I understood it was it
was a cool experience yeah it's fun when
you don't speak the same because even
you just have to make a look or do
something with your hands like everybody
everybody's like a mime all a sudden
yeah the uh the kind of subtle cues of
human behavior become more important the
the facial expressions the body language
the like you know pauses you know stuff
like that and the I love the moment when
you and another person who speak a
different language realize neither one
of you knows how to say what you want to
say yeah so the side they just like yeah
you get to that moment you're like oh
okay uh just kind of maybe I should
thank you for your time try somewhere
else um and you were playing in Japan
right yeah yeah hajim M have you ever
heard that what is it haimi haimi how'
you mean
muste I'm sure I heard it I don't I
think it I think it means our friendship
begin can you look it up Nick if you get
a chance I one time got to go to Japan I
was a student on the sinkhole semester
at C and so we you would go on a cruise
ship and um it was in college and you
would go to different countries around
the world that's cool um our friendship
begins
Watashi no yum
Y how you marim masu okay so a little
off little off right um but we got to go
um and I worked like in the bookstore on
this cruise ship or this school is a
floating university called semester at
Sea that cool yeah it was pretty
exceptional and um we got to go on we
went to coob or Osaka yeah and then we
got to go on a home stay where you would
go and stay with a family for a couple
nights was that down in Osaka too yeah
okay Osaka's cool area is it yeah there
uh the beef there is incredible yeah
like uh it's just we played there a
couple different times throughout the
year and um there's a hotel that like
all the npb teams stay at because they
serve like the dinner and stuff there is
like coob beef and like specialized to
aaka area it's so good it's so good and
uh yeah because that wagu beef that came
out of there right in Japan where's that
from bring it up Nick um yeah that wagu
beef and everybody's like wag they're
like three years ago people started
going crazy what is wagu beef a Japanese
beef
cattle derived from native Asian cattle
wagu refers to all Japanese beef cattle
where why means Japanese and Goo means
cow wow wagu were originally draft
animals used in agriculture and were
selected for their physical endurance
wow so they pick some real gangster meat
you know it's the fatty it's the
intermuscular fat cells marbling so it's
uh you get that um really
rich texture God I want that you know
it's delicious yeah maybe not be the
best thing for you for like an athlete
but it's uh taste-wise it's really hard
to beat and uh when you say npb what is
the teams in J in Japan called so
there's 12 teams um nione professional
baseball um that so npb just like major
league baseball um there's two leagues
there's Pacific League Central league
six teams in each um you got different
team names like the you know the bay
Stars Giants
uh Tigers stuff like that so everyone
it's kind of similar to them it'll be
just smaller uh you know not as many
teams and how uh how was your team we
were good we made playoffs um
unfortunately we lost our first two game
of playoffs and got eliminated um but uh
no we had a good we had a good team a
lot of talented guys um a lot of funny
guys they they were super welcoming too
which was which was great um I mean the
organization as a whole making sure that
foreign players have translators around
even down to like hey what kind of food
do you guys like um trying to have that
in the meal
spreads um just welcoming housing yeah
and Japan I mean if you've been there
you know like it's super clean the
people are super polite super nice like
it culturally it's very different than
the United States in a lot of different
ways and that was one of the things that
really stood out is like how nice the
people are oh yeah on the home stay that
I went on so you you got to go stay with
a family for a couple nights yeah so I
show up over there uh I they speak
Japanese I'm I barely speak English
right and so we're just like dude it so
it's like real quiet and they made like
a little meal for me and uh we just sat
around this little table on the floor
and ate did you so did you have to sit
on the floor yeah I think they might
have put some Wick like a thin mat yeah
and we sat there and then um I guess
when I walked in I gave the lady just a
and a kiss just on the cheek just kind
of how I am um and throughout the next
couple days she would have her friends
come over just so I would hug and kiss
him on the cheek she like Linda Linda
and and like the doorbell would ring in
and and she'd be like do it you know and
so I have to and she just kept having
friends come so I would give up I think
they just thought it was interesting and
then they let me sleep in their room I
think like and I think they slept in the
wall or something I swear they were like
they stood up and like in the wall all
night and just didn't sleep CRA so I
could sleep like it's just a lot of um I
don't know if it's like sacrifice or
just extreme
respect I what do you feel like it is
you don't you don't trying to explain
respect deference um
they so they they what I've what I
learned and I I could be wrong about
this this is just what I've been told
and explained cuz obviously I didn't
grow up there and all that stuff but um
they care a lot about the good of like
the group as opposed like over the good
of the individual yeah so if the
individual needs to sacrifice something
to make the group environment better the
individual is expected or or used to
offering to sacrifice so it makes sense
like if you have a guest in your house
and they could be more comfortable
sleeping on the bed and you can spend a
couple nights not sleeping on the bed I
can totally see how that would be how
that would be a thing yeah it was
baffling man I was just it was like I
felt so respected yeah it it was it was
pretty fascinating I had a similar
experience I you know they were so
respectful that I was like no no I'm I'm
no better than you guys like I'm just
another like we can just be person to
person here and it's not that I'm like
above you or something I almost felt
like I was viewed as being above other
people and I don't like that I just like
I just like to like I'm not better than
you or anyone else I'm just another
normal person let's just like interact
on a fair playing field Level Playing
Field here yeah um I don't like being
like looked down on by people and I
don't like being put on a pedestal by
people and I know they didn't do it
intentionally but it almost felt like
half the time the interactions I did
have with people even just you know fans
out in in the
community taxi drivers uh waitresses um
hosts stuff like that I almost felt like
I was on a pedestal and it was a little
uncomfortable for me yeah yeah but it's
cool like that
they there is that respect and there is
that like deference to the other person
um excited they're almost so excited to
like respect you or to show you how
respectful they can be like that's a
good way putting it yeah um wow what a
what a what a uh interesting experience
just to get to go and and and be there
and like how was it overall it was great
um I've always wanted to do that um so I
had an experience in 2009
um played on Collegiate Team USA and we
had a five game series against the
Collegiate Japan team
and so we played over in Japan played at
like five different stadiums we there
for I think 12 days they were packing
stadiums like 40,000 people for a
college baseball game now I'm coming
from West Coast baseball which doesn't
have the type of fan following as like
the SEC does we we draw like some nights
50 people to a game some nights like
couple hundred people at UCLA and I'm
going to this Stadium this professional
Stadium the Tokyo Dome and there's
40,000 people or something in the Tokyo
dome for a college baseball game it was
crazy and I remember in 2009 saying like
I got to before my career's done I'm
going to play baseball in Japan I'm
going to experience this cuz the fan
culture is so crazy there it's like
European soccer there's like packed and
chanting in the passion everything like
that wow look at these images for a
baseball game bands playing nonstop like
and that was college ball that was
college ball it was you know the
Japanese style they had a band for the
Japanese team but they also provided a
band for the American team so we had a
band playing for us even though we were
the visiting team which is the most
Japanese thing ever it was it was
awesome um so yeah I've always wanted to
do it I you know was happy to have the
opportunity to do that um the travel is
different the the baseball even like the
technical little details of the game
like the way it's played what's
emphasized is different fan culture like
it's it was such a great experience um
the food I'm a huge Sushi fan so like
the first time I went 2009 I didn't have
sushi and it was cuz I didn't have a
translator with me and I didn't know
what I was ordering and I had heard back
then that if there's certain types of
fish that if you eat it and it's not cut
right you can die like puffer fish or
something oh yeah I heard that rumor
going around too people were saying that
in our neighborhood and I'm like
dude none of us are going to eat any
puffer fish we can't you know what I'm
saying but I couldn't tell what it was
on the menu cuz I didn't read you know
Google translate didn't exist back then
in 2009 so I didn't have sushi and that
was one of my regrets so I ate a lot of
sushi this past year to make up for it
yeah yeah dude I remember people like
bro can't have any puffer fish man if it
ain't cut right you could die I'm like
dude we could we're we're lucky
to split a Jimmy John tomorrow like
let's be real like nobody's bringing
puffer fish into our neighborhood dude
like some people are just obtuse man um
so I want to know like how you kind of
started in baseball cuz like like I
think everybody kind of like there's
this like Ambiance in the universe like
there's a lot of information in the
world about how you ended up up like
having to go to Japan or one of the you
know like the some of the overall
reasons because you weren't allowed back
in Major League Baseball yeah but how
did you like get into baseball like like
when you were like who brought it to you
first like what brought it what brought
baseball to you I
think like my earliest memory of
baseball is I had this little plastic
bat called fatbat it was maybe a foot
and a half long had a you know big old
barrel of plastic bat whiffle ball bat
and I remember being out in the front
yard at my house and my dad would toss
me a whiffle ball and I would you know I
would hit the ball and run around the
yard and um we had this little like uh
brick wall that was maybe like you know
one cinder block or two cinder blocks
high so I'd always try to hit the ball
over that for a home run so I must have
been two years old or something at that
point um I think I was always just drawn
to it I always wanted
to yeah like when I was growing up what
I wanted to go do was play baseball
practice baseball I was always out in
the front yard playing pickle or three
flies you're up with some of the
neighborhood kids you know some people
go out and play basketball or football
or whatever like we played baseball on
my block so and where was that at where
were you guys living I was up in
Valencia uh yeah in California um what's
it like there what's Valencia like dude
there's tumble weeds when we moved out
there like open plots and um now it's
all malls and shopping centers and stuff
like that but really nice Community lots
of trees but like planned like
neighborhoods and stuff
so we actually lived uh maybe like a 5
minute bike ride from uh one of the
public parks up there so when I was
growing up I just ride my bike with a
bucket of baseballs up to the park Safe
Community everyone you you just run
around it was a different world back
then I'm 33 now so I'm talking you know
30 years ago I'd be up and down the poos
and out all day and um yeah I I love
Valencia um parents still live there I
still go back all the time oh nice man
yeah so you get out there and ball you
so and that was just a sport that you
kind of took to yeah I played soccer um
I guess or football depending on where
you are in the world um but uh played
that until High School um but when I got
to high school I was in like AP classes
and playing baseball and I didn't have
time for soccer and I was always just
much more drawn to baseball anyway so
yeah never really played any other
sports just been baseball pretty much my
whole life did you collect the cards too
uh I collected baseballs and autographs
more than cards so my dad and I would go
to Spring training every year we'd make
the drive it's like six hours from LA to
to Arizona for oh for the Diamondbacks
uh Diamond there's a bunch of people out
there Diamondbacks um I mean I I
remember when they just put the Royals
and the Rangers facility out there and
they started moving in but the Oakland
A's Cubs have been out there forever
Brewers like a whole bunch of teams I
think there's 15 or 16 teams out in
spring training in Arizona now here we
go right here you have white socks a
Giants wow some great teams um did you
ever get to see Mark Grace out there um
no I don't remember if I saw Mark Grace
but u i remember when Ichiro came over I
guess kind of drawing the Japanese
connection but I remember when like icho
first came to the Mariners and we're
like oh there's this like new guy from
Japan that's supposed to be really good
and this just kind of sensation and then
uh I remember standing there with a ball
outside of the fence at spring training
like ich icho trying to get a an
autograph um and then he went on to be
like just the best hitter that's ever
lived or something you know we had no
idea that he was going to be that
successful but I remember being a little
kid and just standing there at spring
training watching the guys did he sign
the ball I don't think I think he was um
I think he was off to another field or
something I don't remember we had to
know we had to know that's why I yeah um
yeah so that was your world and so you
and then you just became good at it like
like did you love did you just love
practicing it so much like how did it
yeah I love practicing I love I just
like doing anything baseball related so
I was always thinking about it I was
always out playing it so I think I
developed some skills that way and I was
always like goodish but I was never the
best guy I never made like the best
tournament team or the best All-Star
team oh wow even in my freshman year of
high school I was like not the the ace
pitcher um but I also love like math and
physics and I took a class in ninth
grade with a guy Martin Kirby was in a
physics class new Kirby Martin Kirby's a
British guy okay so he had this accent
and like he made class really really fun
Kirby
yeah yeah the Brits dude you just
believe them you know you know
they go home and drink but still he had
a he had a picture um so he used to be a
smoker actually and he quit cold turkey
one day but he put two packs of
cigarettes in his mouth lit them all at
the same time so he had that picture on
the wall like just him with two packs of
cigarettes in his mouth and he said he
like got so sick after that that he just
never wanted to smoke again damn but
yeah he's a he's it was such a fun class
and I started learning about like
physics and how leverage works and
velocity and energy transfer and
momentum and all that and I started
trying to take class and apply it to
baseball and at the same time I went
down to a training facility in Texas
actually for the first time it's a Texas
baseball Ranch and uh they were talking
about some of the same Concepts momentum
and um energy transfer and whip and all
this different stuff and so I that was
really when I started my like my true
devoted like baseball development where
I was trying to take academic
and apply it to baseball and use a
scientific method to like get myself
better oh damn so you brought some real
homeschool energy today deal man I mean
that's but so so that was something that
like that took a once that got added in
like this other kind of world of it that
you could start to see while you were
doing it and stuff and equate yeah then
you really I really kind of lit you up
that's when it took that's how my brain
works too cuz I like I need to have
something that I'm chasing some like I'm
here I want to go there I need to plot a
course and like am I getting closer to
my target or not like that's how my
brain works so as soon as I had like I
knew I always wanted to play in college
that was my goal I never well my goal
growing up was just to play on the high
school team then once I made my freshman
team I was like okay I want to play in
college and that was really when my
development was starting so I was like
okay I want to get to College I'm
currently a freshman in high school I'm
throw this hard I have this pitch I have
this command whatever like I need to
improve these skill sets and so then I
would wake up in the morning at like
5:30 three times a week and go to the
YMCA and do like pool workouts I love YC
don't you yeah yeah we had a membership
there I used to lift there and spent a
lot of time there as a kid I always love
it it just makes me feel like just part
of the universe yeah yeah um I sorry I
interrupted you so you would go there
and you would uh you would just train
practice get ready I'd do that yeah
prior to school then I'd go do school go
straight to practice after school we'd
get done at 4:30 5:00 go home do some
homework and eat and then usually like 7
or 8:00 I'd go up to local park and I'd
be there for an extra 3 hours doing
whatever workout I was doing or throwing
or videoing myself or whatever you know
trying to trying to find some way to get
better and that's just what I I didn't
really like do anything else I didn't
have interest in anything else did you
give a lot of friends like did you have
a social world or you just really did
you and was that kind of a choice you
think you made or you just kind of get
locked in on something and and you
because a lot of people that become
great at something there's there's
sacrifices to it people don't realize
that yeah um I think uh it was partially
that what I wanted to do was baseball so
given the choice of going to the mall to
hang out on a Friday afternoon or going
and doing baseball like I was naturally
gravitated towards baseball also
like
I I'm not really the most like social
person like a lot of my social
interactions I learned a little later in
life starting in college and pro ball
and stuff I just didn't I I viewed
things differently as a kid I was kind
of different I dressed differently I
thought about different stuff my sense
of humor was different than the normal
kids so I struggled I struggled socially
um in high school all you know Junior
High all the way up into high school I
didn't have a a large peer group um you
know I was kind of I was part of two
different groups I was like part of the
athlete group right but I didn't fit in
with them because I was also a nerd oh
yeah and I didn't really fit in with the
Nerds because I was a jock and so I kind
of got pickled between both of those
where I didn't really have a group that
I fit in with like Clark K almost in a
way you know I mean not not quite as uh
as super but yeah but well you would
turn out to be oh here you are right
there go Trevor in this throwback to
when the Astros didn't have to cheat to
win that's it that's tweet oh that's
cool dude does that does that kid look
like uh someone that would fit in so
that's actually a uniform like I would
wear my baseball like pants and uniform
and stuff to school in school so I got I
got picked on a lot yeah but also dude
if you slid in the fourth period you
were a Legend I'll tell you that
you know if the only person that slides
head first in the social studies you
win as far as I'm concerned
today's episode is brought to you by
prize picks if you like firing on Sports
then prize picks is the app for you
instead of choosing teams you choose
individual players that's what I like
about it it's Unique each player has a
set projection and you either choose
more or less than that set projection
for example Le you could choose Isaiah
Pacho more than 51 yards or Brock perie
more than two touchdowns that's right
prize picks is America's number one
fantasy sports app and my favorite place
to fire on Sports if you're smart with
sports and know what players are going
to perform on what nights then prize
picks is the best app for you download
the app and use code Theo
prize picks will match your deposit up
to
$100 keeps baby you want to keep your
hair don't you yeah you do even animals
want to keep their hair everybody wants
it and if you're a husband or just a man
or even a woman you might want to keep
your hair and I don't blame you I like
keep in mine that's for sure get expert
care for hair loss from the comfort of
your home without ever visiting a
doctor's office or Pharmacy keeps helped
me they can help you all treatment plans
are personalized to address your unique
needs and recommended by a licensed
medical provider that's true keeps
offers both of the FDA approved hair
loss treatment options as well as a
2inone gel that combines both treatments
to date keeps has helped nearly 1
million men keep their hair hair loss
stops with keeps for a special offer to
get started go to keeps
. Theo or click the link in the
description that's ke ps.com
EO um wow so you just loved it that much
it kind of became almost or it seems
like I'm just being judgmental but um
like it became like a sense of Pride
that you had then yeah or like you ident
you really identified as like I think it
was my back stop like anything anytime
something would happen in life if it was
you know I was picked on or bullied or
whatever in school like I go to the park
and I would do baseball you know if
something was going good in my life I
was like okay like I'm excited like I'm
going to go do baseball I bonded with my
family over you know on the weekends
growing up we'd have tournaments all the
time so you'd travel on Friday evening
or Saturday morning two or three hours
away you'd play four or five games in a
couple days I was out there with my mom
and my dad my sister my you know whoever
was going sometimes most most of the
time it was my dad sometimes my mom
sister would come along so I have really
good family relationships because of
baseball I have like
baseball's always kind of been my coping
mechanism when something's going wrong I
just go do baseball because that's what
I know and like I'm good at it and I
feel a sense of uh like accomplishment
or progress towards a goal or something
like that and it's fluid to you it
becomes part of your makeup and so you
I'm going to go get back to a good
homeostasis no matter what's going on
highs or lows yeah I think I exercise
helps tends to help with that in general
so because baseball is an active thing
um I think I got kind of the benefits of
both the exercise but also that like
centering of myself um a lot of people
have like video games that they go play
or they go watch a Netflix show or
something like that not saying those
things are wrong but I also think that
baseball some it's because it was
something active I got the physiological
benefits of exercising too which I think
helps stabilize yeah and why the
pitching was the pitching because you
have a lot you have some cool pitches
man uh I stayed up last night I mean
actually really late and then I couldn't
sleep I'm like eight days off nicotine
right now soow I didn't know it was
going to fect bro it like will not let
me sleep are you on like you doing like
patches or what's the I'm on nothing
dude straight up I'm on just light
prayer and just doing my best yeah yeah
you know and it's like but I didn't I
thought it was like three days it's out
of your system dude it is like haunting
at night until you're awake and you're
like what should I do and then your
brain's like maybe you should do some
VAP like what the it like won't let you
it's gone but it won't let you sleep and
then it just starts to be like what
about maybe a puff or two you know you
think that's a you think that's like a
physiological thing or do you think it's
a mental thing like your mind wants it
or you think your body's craving it man
it's a good question um some of it is a
little bit of a bore it's a it habitual
like it become a
boredom thing I I don't have anything I
can't do anything else right now I might
as well do this so maybe a little bit
habitual uh and I think my mind yeah my
mind is like oh I'm frustrated I want to
be sleeping I can't what can I do uh in
frustration cuz a lot of times I if
things were going good or bad Vape
became like a little bit of a habit I
would use interesting um it's
interesting to think about though yeah
because sometimes people just do things
they don't even start to think about why
am I doing it you know like what inside
of me is like beckoning me to this I'll
find myself walking down the
street nothing happens I like think that
my phone vibrated so I reach in my
pocket and check in I'm like oh no no no
ification put it back in my pocket no
more than 30 seconds later I'm like oh
someone just text me but like it's not
vibrating there's nothing there and it's
just I'm so used to reaching for my
phone because of text call social media
notification like whatever you get
programmed over the years to to reach
for your phone so much yeah um so I I
have the same type of experience with
the habitual side of things yeah I think
a lot yeah I've had some I made some
poor I mean I had like pornography I got
into pretty badly when I was like in my
20s and that was was a uh that was a bad
habit um vaping has been the tougher one
as I have gotten older but I don't drink
or do drugs so it's like sometimes I
give myself a little bit of a leeway
yeah but I just like my own energy
better I'm able to sit and have a more
comfortable conversation with people and
so at a certain point it's like I have
to give it up just because I'm missing
out on I'll be short with people you
know I won't want to stay in a moment
because I want to go Vape you know just
like that you you self-reflect a
lot on things do you look at your own
like behaviors and stuff and like
analyze yourself or like how do you get
that feedback yeah I started doing that
more yeah you know I've done like some
IAS over the few years and I bring that
up a lot but that plant medicine that
stuff is really interesting for exactly
that it helps me learn um it's not as
much time that I spend learning
something like say I'll read or write
something or or or be in a class but
it's the time I go sit back with what
I've written yeah and be and and have um
a relation have like a integration
that's what I'm learning is so much more
crucial it's like cuz for so long I was
like kind of learning and getting some
getting information but a lot of things
weren't sticking because the big part I
was missing out on was integration
interesting you know and so I think
that's where some of that comes from and
um being in conversations with getting
be in conversations with some neat
people over the years and makes me start
to think more yeah um and leads me into
like wanting to be more introspective
and and wonder why I do things you know
um I have a brother that helps me think
about that kind of stuff a lot and make
me kind of question you know so I start
to not only be myself but also uh see
myself a little bit that makes any sense
yeah no for sure the the studies on the
iasa and the uh mushrooms and stuff like
that for brain function like uh treating
ptsds and you know past experiences and
stuff like that is pretty interesting
I'm like I follow it decently closely
just because I'm very interested in the
effects of of like the brain and how you
how do you learn something how do you
get over something how do you change
behaviors stuff like that so yeah it's
uh the last couple years there's been a
lot of cool stuff that's come out about
that stuff that was like 10 years ago
kind of demonized and looked at like
this really bad thing now we're starting
to learn a little bit more like oh this
could be useful in like these certain
areas yeah there's like Shades of Gray
in there right it's not just like it's
good or it's bad it's like could be a
useful tool in certain cases it could be
abused in certain cases um yeah yeah
it's interesting yeah I love that I love
that it's that kind of stuffs becoming
like a new modality or whatever whatever
term people use for people to try and
get well you know yeah because it almost
goes really back to Our Roots like
literally back to like it's like Native
American root medicine yeah that they
would use to like really have a better
look at themselves kind of um but I I I
recommend it I think it helps it's
helped me a lot in just having different
ways to think about things yeah um when
did you start being good at B like when
did it start to add up cuz if you're
doing all those unique pitches like some
of the P like you just have such a cool
like assortment of pitches I almost feel
like yeah somebody's rolling up to the
mound this is from your channel right
here yeah oh this is back in uh 11 years
ago yeah W you've had your channel for a
long time yeah I started I think
2011 um to do like you know try to
connect with Baseball fans and like give
some information and then I actually
stopped it for like six or seven years
there from 2013 through maybe 2019 or
2020 I should have kept it going I'd
have a lot more subscribers you got a
great amount of subscribers D 690,000 is
amazing yeah um and did what made you
stop what was the break was you were you
getting busy with baseball no so I
actually got in trouble uh so I when I
was growing up I in high school and
college I watched a guy named Tim linum
and I like studied everything about him
wait did he play for the Giants yeah
yeah and I his college film his Giants
film minor league film like I can still
close my eyes and picture
like the exact delivery from a time from
a video from University of Washington he
was throwing it was like 40 degrees that
night half long sleeve per like I can
see the video in my head um but I
studied him Non-Stop and one of my most
fun things to do in college was every
time he pitched I would go on mlb.com
and I would see the highlights and I
would just watch them over and over and
over and i' got a lot of enjoyment out
of it so I started putting a segment up
on my channel when I signed I was in the
minor leagues there was no way for fans
to watch me pitch in the minor leagues
and have that same experience of
highlights so I would take video clips
from the games make a little highlight
reel I called it weekly whiffs and I
would put it up on YouTube channel and I
did two episodes of it and then the
organization at the time that I was with
at the time was like hey you can't do
that because it was just different no
one was doing that it was right you know
it can be looked at as like you're
trying to embarrass the other hitters or
whatever it had nothing to do with the
hitters I was just trying to entertain
the fans yeah um and so I made a couple
more videos after that like the pitch
grips video in 2013 and a couple slow
motion videos here there but um it kind
of in a way it took a little bit of the
fun of like trying to entertain fans out
uh and so I just I was off of it I went
more towards uh Twitter at the time
which is now X but um trying to just
have that like back and forth connection
with fans and grow it that way um and
that ended up getting me in a lot of
trouble as well unfortunately people
don't like you to have your own voice a
lot of times yeah you know which is we
you know if you're involved in something
that's biger like when you have to go
into organizations like major league
sports college sports where there's a
lot of big business interests on the
back end of things they really don't
like a lot of guys to have their own
voices it seems like they don't you're
not really you're allowed to but are you
really allowed to yeah it's a it's an
interesting my perspective on that has
has changed a good amount recently like
so coming up I was like like okay I'm my
own person I'm going to have my voice
like you as my employeer don't control
me I'm going to say what I want whatever
and that was very kind of bullheaded on
that and then I started a business and I
have employees and I deal with employees
who remind me very much of myself and
they have their own voice and they
express stuff in certain ways and I'm
like okay like I got to handle this a
little bit differently as a business
owner than I with as employee and now I
can understand the different perspective
like I'm still very like I'm very
protective of trying to tell my
employees you can't say this or you can
say this or like putting guidelines on
it but I do see how someone like me
coming up that has these opinions
especially when I would be like critical
of the league like here's an employee of
the league who's being critical of their
boss publicly and like at the time I was
like well this isn't right and this
isn't right and I disagree with this and
blah blah blah and so I would just say
it and then without considering the
opposite perspective and I think I was a
lot more like I canident identify this
problem and I'm just going to say that
there's a problem and blame instead of
now what I really try to do is look and
say okay I identify a problem but what
are some potential Solutions let me
present the solutions that I think and
have a discussion about it instead of
just like hey you're wrong you're wrong
do this this way and whatever so some of
that like Evolution over time growing up
and getting older and learning from past
mistakes starting a business seeing
other perspectives um in your business
you're talking about your YouTube
channel your Trevor bow Channel yeah
it's a cool Channel man yeah we have
Trevor Boward Channel we have also
momentum uh Channel and ER and Eric Sims
Channel we all we're kind of like a
Content group um so M momentum is the
company and it's started in 2019 to grow
baseball entertain Baseball fans and so
we bring people in um D wow you have a
lot of sub subscri Subs the kids call
them you got a lot of Subs on there man
yeah Eric just passed I think he's at
like 520 now as well so I'm at 690
momentum's at 6 or 567 Eric's over 500
as as well we got a couple other
creators that come in the idea is
basically you bring guys in that love
baseball that have a good personality
you have a group Channel where they can
get exposure to a lot of people
entertain a lot of people and then they
end up growing their brands and can go
in their own different directions you
have someone that does gaming you have
someone that does Action you have
someone that does you know card reviews
you have someone that does whatever and
so you start branching out and
entertaining all factions of Baseball
fans and growing the game organically
where the audience is you know one of
the things that I think NBA was probably
the first sport to really adopt it is
the social media push like delivering
content to fans where the fans are M um
I mean you go on NBA or you go on
Twitter X or whatever social media
platform when the playoffs are going on
in NBA it's like the second Steph Curry
hits a three like it's everywhere yeah
right you have the same opportunities in
baseball where was like hard to find
content and so I was like okay this is a
problem but instead of just like blaming
I'm gonna like try to actually do
something about the problem so momentum
is kind of my attempt to like help
impact the marketability of players help
impact the growth of the game you know
young people aren't playing baseball
nearly as much anymore there's so many
other opportunities um you got streaming
services so they can watch on their iPad
you got gaming that's huge Esports um
people aren't outside as much playing so
the game is like shrinking a little bit
at the Youth Level so trying to trying
to grow it in in ways where kids will
consume the content get interested in it
yeah man dude that's so Kudos bro just
to be a be be a part be doing something
uh your job but then also create wanting
to create this other more of your job
kind of you know like um this is's not a
lot of guys that have that have their
own channels like that yeah baseball's
given me a lot oh yeah this chart's uh
this chart's sad this is Sheriff
children aged 6 to 12 who participate in
baseball on a regular basis in the
United States from 2008 to 2020
yeah and in 2008 it says 16.5% and now
we're down to 12.6% yeah it's down like
25% in the last 15 years I'm kind of
shocked because I know we have a like a
larger growing Latino culture you know
and I know baseball's big in Latino
cultures you know why do you think that
is why do you think there's been like a
tail off like that well I think
uh basball has gotten
expensive um the equipment's very
expensive the travel team very
expensive um also baseball isn't doesn't
have the cool factor that NBA has NBA
has sneakers and and like rap culture
pop culture they've Blended the two
together in a very cool way that's a
good point and so when you're going
through high school and you're trying to
figure out who you are like you want the
you want to be part of the cool crowd
and it's the sneakers it's the the new
rapper the new album It's the entertain
it's and that's synonymous with NBA yeah
uh baseball hasn't had the same like uh
success in blending and getting the cool
factor for young kids yeah baseball
always was like the it was the kids
would go off and do it in high school
but you didn't really know you didn't
and a lot of times you
wouldn't it wouldn't be a part of the
pep rallies a lot of times and stuff so
yeah there was always missing a little
bit of that football you have the
crossover you have like the cheerleaders
and you have the football players and
these are you know there's like
integration of like the whole school
right and it's one game and the school
shows up and it's our school versus your
school and so there's a lot of
involvement around football NBA has the
pop culture
integration baseball's struggled to get
that their thing
um and you
know it's uh there's a lot of games so
it's not like if you miss out on this
game there's not going to be a game
tomorrow right so good point uh and it's
always been that baseball has like an
older demographic it's a slower game I
think his attention spans are shrinking
Tik toks around Shorts YouTube shorts
Instagram reels all this stuff attention
is
shrinking the Cadence of baseball is
slow right um where NBA it's like 20
seconds and then there's a new play and
then this and then that football it's
like there's always something going on
baseball it's like well there's you know
four minutes in between Innings and then
there's 30 seconds in between a pitch
like one of the things they tried this
year is like a pitch clock so shrink the
time in between pitches which has
seemingly made the game more popular
yeah I feel that I felt that energy when
I went to some games this year it felt
faster it felt a little bit more and it
kept you a little bit involved because
it was just enough time where you didn't
kind of zone out and go get on your
phone of that extra five or six seconds
yeah like even when we're saying that
extra habitual moment where you kind of
start to check out I would stay involved
you know we went to see Zach gallon
pitch a couple times which was really
cool um who else did we go oh going to a
Padre's game is so much fun man that
Park is so much fun you go in San Diego
yeah yeah dude that Park is so much fun
they do a good job down there um when so
padr and Dodgers were oh yeah a lot of
lot of rivalry going back there Dodgers
players won't say it's rivalry but it's
a rivalry right um and so we' you know I
in 2021 I was with the Dodgers we'd go
down play in Padres and it was like so
loud and so cool the Stadium's like
pretty compact you you got the you got
the industrial building out there that
kind of squeezes things together and
they pack it full it's really energetic
and uh yeah we played some really fun
games down there is such a fun place to
uh to be a part of it's cool it's right
downtown the backdrops really cool
you're right by the ocean the weather's
always great like you literally you
leave the stadium and you're there's
bars right there just right downtown the
best area they got some great players
down there too man um no no Joe is one
of my buddies who pitches over there
he's he's he's awesome um yeah but uh
you darish
Machado uh tatis yeah they're just it's
fun that's that's a fun place to see a
game um so how did so when did you start
to like when did you like be like okay
I've got the mechanics uh I've been
working on this so much myself I have my
own interest in it when did you start to
be like good and what was that like so I
was I was good my freshman year I was
good my sophomore year in high school
cool I made I made varsity team towards
the end of my sophomore year but then I
really like I really exploded my junior
year of um of high school my velocity
jumped a lot I was throwing in the 90s I
struck a lot of people out I had like a
sub one ER for the year started getting
a lot of uh yeah I think it was like 79
ra or something I don't remember the
exact number but um gosh yeah struck out
like uh 106 people I think in 72 Innings
or something along those lines so I had
a really good year I went 12-0 that year
our team was really good um actually the
there's a senior pitcher I was a junior
Mike Montgomery was a senior um he was
getting a lot of looks he ended up
getting drafted in the first round by
the Royals that year so we had a lot of
scouts out at our games wow so you had a
lot of influence to see that this could
really happen right I mean he's right
there ahead of you and this happens in
front of you so baseball is such a small
world too that like in the 2016 World
Series the last person to throw a pitch
for the Cubs Michael Montgomery the last
person to throw a pitch for the Indians
me wow high school teammates we're the
last ones to throw pitches in that for
our respective teams in that World
Series but uh yeah and so he was good
and I don't like losing to people on my
own team I don't like losing period like
I'm a super intense competitor so like
he would go have a start and I'm like
okay I gotta be better than that and
then that really drove me to be better
and so actually I ended up graduating
high school half a year early and so I I
never played my senior season in high
school I just went to
UCLA to go went start yeah so I
graduated December I think 18th and I
started UCLA January 4th and then I
played what would have been my senior
season of high school as my freshman
year in college you must been one of the
younger pitchers that year yeah younger
P one of the younger pitchers I was
actually the Freshman pitcher of the
year in all of NCAA that year and that's
after that year is when I made Team USA
and went played in Japan in 2009 as
basically a high school senior so so
what happens in that space cuz like um
and pitching is so perfect for you it
sounds like cuz it's your own little war
that you're in you're like this this
Orchestra you're the you're this guy but
you're also the guy playing the you know
it's like um it's you versus them it's
very clearcut how things go um what uh
oh dang I had a great question um it
probably wasn't that great but I thought
it was pretty decent um this is my brain
checks out every now and then but hold
on I'm stay with this what uh what about
did your ego did Ego start to build up
cuz that's one thing I always talk about
a lot in here just like our ego and what
that's like you know cuz what was it
like when you start to get like a claim
for that if you're kind of have this
social uncomfortability yeah I um I've
always tried to separate ego on and off
the field um I haven't been great at it
but I think having an ego on the field
is super important like when you walk
out there you got to know that you're
the best you have to believe that you're
better than him and him and him
and you got to feel like you're the best
guy out there to be like the true like
competitor you know off the field like
going around telling everybody that
you're better than them and acting like
that's not great right so uh I'm not
naturally like inclined to be
egotistical I because the way I view
things it's never like a static Point
everything is I'm improving or I'm
getting worse it's a it's a fluid
situation and so if I'm either getting
better or getting worse I'm on a a
journey just like you're on a journey
you have your struggles and your your
successes I have my struggles and
successes I view myself as like even
with every other person but on the field
like when it's competition time like I
am the best person on the field and if
I'm not that day it's
because like I didn't work hard enough
or I need a better process but like
every time I step on the field I have to
believe that I'm the best person there
and I've had times in my career where I
lost that belief and it was there those
were very dark times performance wise I
was terrible on the field and I had to
like trick myself and like fake like
fake it in my own mind that I was still
good and then when I started doing that
the results came back but wow um yeah
it's interesting at levels of success
how you have to sometimes trick yourself
to stay there how you have to use little
manipulations life hacks all those
there's so many different things that so
many different people who are top
performers in their in their world or
sport or whatever it is line of work uh
do I think I'm a little predisposed to
uh depression for whatever reason I
don't know if it's something chemical or
or what it is I'm a very like kind of
flat personality I don't have like a ton
of highs and lows so when baseball would
go bad like my mood would go
really bad and I had to find a way to
kind of pull those two things apart and
be regardless of baseball is up or down
I needed to be able to like be okay in
my life um and what you do to go did you
like would you like if when things got
bad how would you would you booze a
little like how would your world know so
I've never I've never been drunk I've
never done drugs
um wow bro you are you are riding the
world like yeah that's in that's
int it's incredible man it's I didn't
have friends to invite me to the parties
in high
school I never got started but um yeah I
would like when I would have it early in
my career let's say prior to uh let's
say July
2017 um I would have a bad outing and I
would go home and I would study it for
hours and hours and I would be up till
4: or 5 in the morning and then I
wouldn't sleep well and then I'd be Mis
the next day cuz I'm like okay I should
have done all these things that I didn't
do and now my results are bad and we
lost the game and I'm this and that and
whatever um and then I was just 20 the
the start of 2017 was like the worst
half of baseball that I've had and I had
like a seven or eight erra gosh that's a
lot I could have that probably no I mean
it probably couldn't any anyone any
number of people yeah some people could
let's just say some people could have it
yeah and uh sorry man that was kind of
offensive but no no I mean it's true
it's just a fact I was bad and I had to
trick myself into believing that I was
good wow because I'm so analytical that
I was like I am the worst pitcher in
Major League Baseball right now
factually and I had to pull myself out
of that and somehow trick myself on the
field to thinking that I was good and
then I also had to pull myself a split
myself from baseball so I could find a
way to be okay personally in
life and um so I had to start developing
some other interests some stuff that
when I went home I would get interested
in that thing instead of studying
baseball so much and then from 2017 on
outside of two months at the end of 2019
I was probably like a top 10 pitcher in
baseball and but that that split of like
being okay personally and finding a way
to kind of like level out that
depression and um some of those you know
really down moments um made me better
and more stable at doing my job on the
field as well and would you go spend
time with the guys after the games or
would you still kind of Do Your Own
Thing a lot so baseball is uh because
night because games are played at night
like when you get out of the field it's
11:15 11:30 yeah so if you're going to
go spend time with the guys it's like
what bar are you going to what club are
you going to there's not a whole lot of
other options on the road sometimes you
go back to the hotel room go play cards
have a glass of wine or something in
someone's room and hang out with the
guys um but it's not like you're just
going to dinner at 7:00 and having a
nice night so um I would typically just
go from the field back home most of the
time you do you spend with guys during
season is like prior to the game so you
get there at noon or 1 play cards in the
Clubhouse play some video games joke
around whatever or Day games when you
get done at 4: and you can go to dinner
those are usually like Sundays if you're
not traveling um do you find yourself in
Social atmospheres do you feel pretty
uncomfortable like how do you how do you
feel like in Social atmospheres do you
feel pretty has it changed over time
yeah it's uh it's definitely changed I'm
very very uncomfortable around large
groups of people that I don't know um
I'm not very good at like starting a
conversation um you know I just I think
too much and so when I look at another
person I'm like well they don't want to
talk to me and like what am I going to
say and well how do I not come off I
don't want to come off awkward and
disturb him but I also like kind of want
to talk to him but I and I just I just
don't do I just think too much where I
watch some guys they just like go up hey
how's it going and they like have a
great conversation I'm like damn yeah
and then they're married to him you're
like God that
guy doing great man that's awesome yeah
dude sometimes I would always Marvel at
people that just had that disposition to
be able to be comfortable yeah man I
remember there's a WWE wrestler The Miz
is his name and um he was just he was
always so comfortable wherever he was
and it was the I I never saw anybody
like it the guy just and he just it was
just effortless you know and that was
one thing I was always so envious of
certain people that had they didn't have
to fight inside of themselves to be
comfortable and you know and that that
was always like something I really uh I
just noticed a lot yeah I'm comfortable
with myself right but I'm not
comfortable like going into like unknown
groups and like just somehow integrating
myself now if I know a couple people and
were out like I'm fine like meeting one
of their friends and having a
conversation like talk to someone all
night but I'm not the one that's like I
don't know how to go start those
conversations you might have a freaking
hit of the tism I got it you know what
I'm saying no judgment dude some of the
greatest like people of our time now
have I think a low-key dose you know you
know 7even eight% I think I wouldn't I
wouldn't be surprised yeah it's awesome
man yeah I mean Elon Musk definitely is
riding you know he's riding some Bezos
has it for sure um a lot of the greats
have it some people think that Mike
Tomlin is that his name the football
coach right yeah he you know you don't
see a lot of dark tism going on but I
bet he's got a dose um but yeah I think
there's a lot of it out there it's
creeping up on all of us but I think
it's helping in some ways it's because I
think we some of us are having to evolve
we've gotten into such a uh digital and
like a world that is uh that if you have
are able to conceptual I
things almost a little more
electronically sometimes it's a light
word I'm using but that you have more
success because we're just becoming more
like hypothetically like robots as
people so it just kind of makes sense
make any sense to you yeah yeah for sure
I mean prior to social media if you're
going to get information you're going to
read a book you're going to ask people
around you're going to be in the
community and like learn from people
around you so your habits of uh
ingesting information were reliant on
being able to have those interactions
you're outside more there was less to do
on your phone personally like less
connection digitally there was no
connection digitally for a long time
yeah your grandpa was like shitty Google
remember you go to your grandpa yeah
remember thesaurus yeah yeah dud got to
go look up into thesaurus now you just
chat GPT or Google it or whatever yeah
you can now you can just you don't even
have to you can like go to my fake
family.com and just pick out a family on
there and they'll send you a picture of
you in a family and you frame it and put
you're like who the are these
people just yeah it's a different
universe but it's kind of fascinating if
we don't look at it that kind of stuff
as a negative I think sometimes we look
at it as we're part of evolution you
know in a way so sometimes that's kind
of interesting to me this episode is
sponsored by better help you know if
you're struggling with something if
something there's a specific thing maybe
you can't handle it anymore or maybe
it's just a general feeling of
depression or
uncertainty some of that's normal but
some of it isn't and if you feel like
you need help then better help is a
great place to try that's for sure I've
used better help it's entirely online
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
the license therapist and switch
therapists anytime for no additional
charge become your own soulmate whether
you're looking for one or not visit
betterhelp.com theot today to get 10%
off your first month that's better
HP
help.com Theo betterhelp
hp.com Theo you know that little guy
with the uh hat and glasses when you
open up incognito mode for a little late
night research well that guy is seen
some things hasn't he good thing to know
he can keep a secret uh nah he can't he
doesn't even with Mr incognito on duty
every single thing you've ever clicked
on is fully visible to anyone who owns
your Wi-Fi who's that you ask uh I don't
know your work your school's it
Department your parents sounds like you
need
expressvpn that's what we're using
expressvpn is an app that sends 100% of
your traffic through their encrypted
servers so your eclectic taste in cinema
cannot be seen by anyone it's like a
super incognito mode that actually works
I love expressvpn so much I even got
them to give you an incredible deal if
you use my special link
expressvpn.com
Theo you'll get three extra mons
completely free that's ex P SS VP vn.com
Theo to help support the podcast and get
three extra months of expressvpn
absolutely free this episode is
sponsored by Blue chew Let's Talk About
Sex yeah fellas remember the days when
you were already ready to get going and
you were just ready to do some sex but
maybe something's changed who knows well
now you can increase your performance
and get that extra confidence in bed
bluechew.com that's right bluechew is a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as Viagra Calis
and Levitra but in chewable tablets and
at a fraction of the cost that's right
blue choose tablets are made in the USA
and prepared and Shi direct to your door
in a discrete package chew your way to
that freaking wonderful Wier bab you can
do it we got a special deal for our
listeners try blue free when use our
promo code Theo at checkout just pay $5
shipping that's
bluechew.com promo code Theo to receive
your first month free visit
blue.com for more details and important
safety information and we thank blueo
for sponsoring the podcast it must be
interesting to be you though because you
it's I feel like when there's more going
on in your head as much as it is a curse
it's also kind of there's enough of a
world going on where you're kind of
you're dealing with that yeah you know
there's a lot of stimulation yeah um I
don't do well when I'm bored like my
mind needs something to be working on so
there's never a shortage of that um but
I think that's why getting into business
has been very beneficial for me
because I don't have those like blank
moments or blank hours where I yeah I I
would I would fill those early in my
career I'd fill them going on Twitter
for three hours and tter so much fun it
was so much fun and I I had fun with it
yeah but I think me having fun with
people is usually like playful banter
like I'll kind of like throw a little
like jab your way and you throw on back
my way and it's like because it's
jousting match and I like that because
it's witty and it forces me to think and
like it's and I'm having these
conversations with people and I'm like
laughing and joking with them in person
and you get a sense of like I'm not
being serious you can tell very clearly
that I'm not being serious but on
Twitter doesn't come across that way and
especially not even though the person
that you're doing it with may feel that
way may not other people reading it
might get really confused and so I would
banter with a lot of people and I think
it got construed negatively by the media
I know it got construed negatively by
the media the larger media as a whole
and then I get this reputation of being
combative and stuff and I was never
doing it from a compatitive standpoint I
understand how it looks that way and how
it came off that way and so those blank
hours where I was just had nothing to do
and I was just like joking with people
on Twitter firing stuff off got you know
got me in trouble um Trump has a great
Dave port I interviewed Donald Trump and
he goes you ever just like he like would
you s was he asking Nick about
proofreading some of his tweets or
something Trump's like yeah you ever
just fire something off and just go to
bed and just hope it's okay and Trump
was like get all all the time you know
you're like what the hell is going on
yeah but you do that if you think about
Twitter being a parallel to like real
life like you someone says something to
you and you just fire away because if
you pause for 5 seconds to think about
what you're going to say it almost like
gives you the Yips like you almost don't
know how to respond then CU we're so
conditioned like you say something and
I'm I'm like I have a response right but
if have you ever thought about what
proof reading like in real life would
look like like you would ask me
something and I would think of my
response and then I would pause for five
or six seconds and really think through
my response and then I might say
something slightly differently can you
imagine a conversation like that if it
was like you say something and I pause
for like 10 seconds and then say
something back to you and then you pause
for like 10 seconds and like really
actually think through it like that we'd
be like processing our answer and then
it be printed out for the person kind of
it'd be so bizarre be so bizarre it'd be
almost like a script then yeah probably
it would be a very awkward conversation
it's not like a normal human tendency to
have an interaction like that so when
some when you read something it's like
oh someone just said something and I'm
going to say it now it takes longer to
type it but you're still having the
thought and so you never have the option
in person to like okay I just said this
now let me proofread it let me read it
again let me check for this my friend is
this okay is this weird yeah but on on
Twitter then it's like the expectation
now for you know people in the public
eye um is that you would proof read it
and then you would check with the
publicist or you would check with you
know someone or whatever you make sure
it was and just not the normal flow of
conversation now it might be in the
future as the as Humanity moves more
towards a digital presence like maybe
that's what happens it's going to be sad
it's not uh it's not normal yeah it's
certainly abnormal what was that thing
did you bring it up Nick what Trump
had oh por I asked the president if he
ever regrets any of the content he posts
often too often Trump said it used to be
in the old days you'd write a letter and
you'd say this is this letter is really
big you put it on your desk and you go
back tomorrow you say oh I'm glad I
didn't send it right we don't do that
with Twitter right we put it on
instantaneously we feel great and then
you start getting phone calls did you
really say
this half the time it's like damn I
didn't I never and I never would have
thought that that would be interpreted
that way thought twice about it yeah oh
it's ridiculous now and then people like
take it down people say it's like it's
definitely it's weird it's weird the way
that we communicate now how foreign it
is and I think also how like as humans
we're not supposed to adapt to the way
we communic like it's so abnormal to
Nature our nature I think that a lot of
it ends up making us feel sick or
confused sometimes I'll send stuff to
Nick and I'll be like is this okay you
know do I seem chill does it seem crazy
am I Gay's like dude this is fine bro
you're just you're doing fine but it's
like I think yeah and as you have some
notoriety especially for your sport um
I'm sure like the the microscope gets
even even tougher um okay so you get
through so you're going through the
major leagues yeah you have some there's
some great videos of you out there like
impersonating like other players and
stuff dude so funny man so when when do
you start to get the entertainment
aspect how did that kind of come into
you do you feel like I think when I got
comfortable that I was good and that
I had largely like established myself
where I was going to be able to have a
career like early in your career you're
just fighting to stay there and it's
like if you have a bad outing you might
not be there the next day but once you
get to a certain level it's like okay I
have some leeway here I can't be bad
forever but if I have a bad start or two
it's not going to be like I'm gone and
so that gives you a little becomes
manageable yeah and it gives you a
little sense of
like settle in you can take a breath you
can be a little bit more comfortable and
then you start having some of these
longer standing relationships with guys
on your team because now you've been
teammates for two three four years um
and you have some of those jokes and
like each game and moment becomes a
little bit less serious because because
of that comfortability and then you have
you can start joking around and you can
start having fun um so really like 2018
I had a really good second half of the
Year 2017 really good start to 2018 and
I started like
feeling more like comfortable and like
settled with the team and I started you
know entertaining I'm
pretty like I'm I like the banter like
we talked about I like the kind of witty
interactions and so I like figuring out
the puzzle of how do I like take this
normally mundane thing and just put a
little twist on it like make it more
entertaining for people and then yeah
starting in like
2020 really after I started the media
company um momentum in 2019 it was like
okay this is an attention economy so in
order for baseball to grow there have to
be clips that are viral enough to get to
the youth that they see it like oh
baseball's fun right and then I'm like
okay how do I start making some of these
viral Clips well let me study NBA what
goes viral in NBA uh when people do
something like they dunk on someone and
they celebrate it like when LeBron's
flexing on someone like that's
everywhere right when Curry hits a three
but before he the ball's in the bucket
he's already running down the court like
celebrating it because he knows it's in
like that's everywhere so like okay how
do you apply some of that to baseball
it's like all right what can you do in
baseball like are you going to celebrate
a strikeout that'd be comparable to like
flexing on someone when you dunk on them
right are you going to call your shot on
you know the day before the game I'm
going to do this with this person are
you going to have some sort of you know
what does that look like in baseball
it's a good point yeah and so I started
getting the entertainment aspect of it
because I was settled with the
performance like I can entertain or and
compete at the same time right so I can
compete and just not do any
entertainment and you're going to get
the same level of performance out of me
that you'll get if I'm also doing a
little bit of entertainment um because
I've it's like my base operating level
is intense compet ition D you're an
interesting dude bro I'm all messed up
my mind's my mind's it's cool it's just
neat to get a look at how you operate
man it's it's really interesting I
appreciate you talking with me man um
yeah because you're you're but you're
right though if you're trying to build
this sport that's what you have those
are the you need some of those moments
yeah you know like the um there's a
video out there and it's a bunch it's
it's of you just impersonating some of
the other players on your team I think
when you're with the um yeah the Indians
we're in Pittsburgh with the Indians it
was uh shout out Sunshine Clevenger over
there too dude yeah you know Mike yeah
yeah definitely uh been around Mike man
he's he's such an entertaining guy yeah
um so this is uh this is a funny story a
lot of people don't know like the
followup to this story so you can see
the guys in the background of this video
have rain uh like tarps on or whatever
so it's raining right so you're in a
raining game and this is here Cleveland
versus Pittsburgh what year is this this
is
2018 maybe I don't
and as you come up to bat here you keep
kind of impersonating I guess different
players on your team their batting
stances yeah yeah so we had a lot of
unique batting stances this year um and
so always like we get four days off in
between starts as a starting pitcher so
we're in The Dugout just messing around
like we don't have anything to do and so
I was always grabbing something and
trying to impersonate you know mik AIS
Jason Kipnis Raburn brandle like some of
these guys that had really unique
characteristics and so um at one point
think it was M was like hey when are you
going to do that for real like you won't
and I was like I'll do it so I go and I
have this at bat where I you know do
rurn and kipness and were they all
shocked they were all if you look at the
dug I don't know if there's a view of it
they're all like laughing yeah there
that's Mike right there he just it yeah
seems like such a neat guy huh Kip's
awesome yeah so the followup to this
though is I get I walk in this bat and
so I'm on first base and I'm just this
stupid pitcher like you know running the
bases and whatever and so the catcher
you know obviously the you Pittsburgh
wasn't super like oh they're applauding
again cool Pittsburgh wasn't super like
pleased with that oh CU they're like you
guys are joking around out here yeah so
right after that the next pitch like I
take my lead off first and the catcher
catches the ball and like fakes like
he's going to throw it down first base
was nowhere close but I'm not used to
being on base because I suck as a hitter
I'm never on base right so he goes to
throw it down to first and I freak out
and I like dive back and there's no
first baseman there it's muddy and I
stick in the mud and I don't even make
like my hand sticks I don't even make it
back to the base I'm just laying there
by the base looking around there's no
one there the catcher never threw the
ball and I'm covered in mud yeah and he
just like pointed at me and like threw
the ball back to the pitcher I'm like
all right all right that's good you got
me that's good I respect
that yeah that's classic that's such a
neat thing about life too how it works
it's like the second you start to get on
your high horse even just a little like
knock you down here you go there there's
another really good example that we're
playing the Padres 2021 we're at Dodger
Stadium um and I facing I'm facing uh
Eric Hosmer now I knew hos from he was
in Kansas City when I was with Cleveland
so we played each other a lot so we have
a little bit of a you know a history
like playing each other so the first at
bat I throw him a curveball he like half
swings at it and strikes out and I like
hit him with my sword celebration and uh
the next the batty comes up I throw him
a curveball instead of missing it he
hits a rocket right back at my face like
it would have it would have killed me if
I didn't get out of the way I end up
like laying on my back and I'm like
laying that on the M like what just
happened fortunately didn't hit me and
he's over at first base and I start to
sit up and there's actually a picture of
me yeah this is probably it is this yeah
that right and I don't know if this
video clip goes long enough but uh see
if I laugh right here yeah yeah right
there so he's at first base he like hey
and I look over at him and he uh he gave
me the sword back back so I got him the
I got him the pit that the had bat
before and then he just like got me back
and then let me know about it tatis had
a great one he had a home run off me
like put one one hand over his eye cuz
in spring training I had like thrown in
a bat with one eye closed and then
against the padr and then they waited
and then when he got me back he put his
eye his hand over do you mind this stuff
you think it's fun I love it yeah it's
cool actually dude if people if people
would like celebrate on me all the time
I don't care like that's good for the
game yeah dude and it would be so kind
of there's one thing like Savannah
bananas you know you see them yeah there
sh some of their shit's gotten crazy
they're like doing the Newsies the
musical between second and third
inning you're like Jesus Christ
90 minute musical like let's get the
game going you know uh but it's also
there's something that's just fun about
um just a little bit of the of the
adding more to it and I think you're
right I think if you you know there's a
little bit
more Ambiance between some of the
players MH it definitely right there
you're like oh he's GNA it's almost
like when you you know that um like Gary
pton was gonna guard uh Michael Jordan
or something like oh I want to I want to
tune in because I know that four times
they're going to face each other let's
see how this shakes out I mean
Strickland and dupi just fought right
yeah that fight was not really
interesting until they had the little
Skirmish in the crowd and Strickland
like through the elbow and they fought
and then everyone's like oh we got to
watch this fight and the fight it was a
great fight like I thought Shawn won
personally but what you think about it I
thought it was 3-2 I thought he
outstruck he outstruck him um didn't
think that dupi got much out of the
takedowns a lot of takedowns but not a
whole lot came from them um I don't hate
the decision like very close fight could
have gone either way I had it I had it
3-2 Strickland judges had it 3-2 dupy
you like the fights yeah I'm a big UFC
fan yeah oh cool bro me too yeah I feel
like do I feel like there should be a
little more gravity if you're going to
give the belt away that's what it felt
like to me I was like it's this close
and you're going to give the belt away
like if you're going to beat somebody
for the belt there should be a little
more gravity to it yeah should be like
definitive you beat them yes yeah like
if it's a regular match I get it yeah
but and maybe that's I'm just a somebody
who sits in the crowd and and wishes
they could be tough enough to be out
there but um yeah I wouldn't want to be
in the ring but you know one of the
things you said earlier made me think
what I've heard a lot of guys say
they're like they can be great guys neat
guys but they have to believe when they
go in there that they are the baddest
in the world because if
they don't believe that yeah the the
what can happen is just they don't stand
they're not giving themselves any sort
of a chance yeah you know yeah God and
that's just got to be I can't imagine
like what that what the walk must be
like like it's you and another human
like in a death match yeah like it's got
to be a crazy adrenaline rush but it's
also got to be super scary like
I walking out to play a baseball game
like you win you lose it sucks if you
lose but like there's not that visceral
consequence yeah like you out there you
I don't think they've ever had a death
in UFC but like you get seriously hurt
like bad yeah and some of the guys they
seem already hurt before they ever
fought you're like damn this guy he
needs to keep whatever he's got still in
the tank he's got a he can't lose
anymore yeah you know oh but yeah the
fact that they and they love it that's
the crazy thing some of them yeah they
love it like you could see sometimes
like gaii or pory just how like just
that's that's their thing yeah
that lights them up imagine only getting
to perform like twice a year too that's
the toughest part I hate I hate baseball
Cadence where I only get to play once
every fifth or sixth day I can't imagine
twice a year once a year yeah yeah
imagine once a year Trevor bow gets to
come out and throw some and and pitch a
game for like 20 minutes God can you
imagine training for a
year and then you get 20 minutes and it
like it could be over in 30
seconds I can't it's almost like I think
penguins are only fertile for like 11
minutes out of the Year oh really yeah
that's a crazy stat I never heard that
before so it's almost like
that
um but yeah if you find anything on that
Nick let me know i' almost I got a buddy
said he had some shouldn't say this but
he had the option if I wanted to get a
little bit of penguin meat which would
be crazy to eat but I've had puffing
have you really in Iceland yeah oh my
God Trevor Puffin kangaroo Puffin
Icelandic
horse shark shark was terrible oh yeah
the fermented shark so like ferment the
shark and they freeze it and they serve
it in these like little cubes it's like
a delicacy in Iceland and they love it I
it tastes like gasoline I couldn't D it
was I don't know had a acquired taste
for sure oh yeah yeah especially yeah
and if you've had real gasoline dude
it's like you don't want anit
yeah you want the real thing but yeah
I've had reindeer somewhere I've had
owl had uh what else if I wanted to have
I wouldn't I don't know if you want to
have penguin though you know people just
love him to I just yeah they're kind of
like the French Bulldog of the north I
feel like yeah like you couldn't imagine
eating french bulldog no you Frenchies
are way too cute yeah that's the thing
people people would be pissed I now it
would taste good I bet ah I'm not even
go down that route I know some Frenchies
and I know people that love their
Frenchies I can't even imagine but yeah
yeah let's don't even say anything else
about
it um so you get to your career's going
you a Sai Young winner y that had to be
unbelievable are you chasing that at a
certain point of the season does it get
like where you're almost like the
drivers in NASCAR where it's like you're
I chased that for 10 years wow so I went
to college and like I said earlier I I
studied Tim linicum mhm and he won a
golden spikes award which is basically
the Heisman Trophy of baseball goes to
like the best college baseball player
and I went to college and my only goal
not my only personal goal like I wanted
to win the College World Series and
everything like that with my team but my
personal goal was to win the golden
spikes award and I won that my junior
year of college so like check that box
off did you really I didn't know that
dud congratul that's you were the best
player in college baseball yeah the one
one yeah wow bro yeah was pretty cool um
mainly because like I set a goal and I
spent literally all of my time I like
should have gone to class more like
didn't I just did not go to school but
it was like baseball and just my
thoughts my like training everything was
just like on that and I accomplished it
and it's like a sense of Pride that I
could set a goal and like accomplish it
it wasn't the ego of being the best guy
it was the fact that I set a goal wow
and like worked my way and actually
accomplished that go goal and so after
that I was like okay what's next I'm
like well Tim won two sa young Awards I
think he has he might have had three I
think he has I know he has two and I was
like okay that's the new goal and so
from 2011 when I won the golden spikes
for the next 10 years I was chasing the
sa Young Award and everything I did was
like okay who's the best pitcher in
baseball what do they do better than I
do and like let me go work on that and
it's did he get uh oh yeah three-time
World Series champion two time S Young
Award yeah back to back 08 and 09 dude
he was you're halfway there those two
years
[Music]
were guess I remember that something
different like it was just
so so unique what Tim was able to do um
Tim linicum yeah yeah and so I yeah from
2011 he had the long hair too remember
yeah God to be able to do so well with
long hair too you know Randy Johnson did
that or eckerle did that there just it's
a special yeah just be like yeah my hair
and then go out there and throw
total gas on people that's crazy yeah
what were you saying he won oh so he won
he won two of them I won it in so I won
the golden spikes 2011 I was like I I I
want the sa young and so everything I
did for the next 10 years was centered
around like what does the best pitcher
do that's better than am and like let me
develop that skill set what pitch does
he throw how hard does he throw is he
durable what's his command how's his
nutrition like all this stuff and so I
just worked at it and then 2020 I won
the sa young um which is like
a the the pitching coach at with the
Reds um Derek Johnson I've been I've
known Derek for he's like one of my guys
I've known him since 2000 since I was
getting recruited to college I wanted to
go to Vanderbilt and play for music
Vanderbilt at the time but he's like in
the baseball circles that I kind of run
in Caleb cam was the assistant pitching
coach he was uh I trained with him for
years in off dog he guys your dogs uh
Eric Jaggers was there like he was um I
trained with him and like one of my guy
like all my people Sunny gray was there
like all my all my people were there and
like to have that year it was super
special um do they get also a copy of
the no so they give outward they give
out one award um but for my catchers I
got them uh they're both kind of like
watch guys so I got got uh we all got
like rolex's I let them pick their their
watch and it all has like 2020 NL sa
young engraved wow dude look how happy
look man yeah yeah and actually this was
um we were playing the Reds uh this day
so uh sunny and Lou Castillo and DJ
actually came over for the ceremony I
have some pictures with them so you w it
with the Reds but you didn't get the
award till the next season yeah when you
were playing with the Dodgers wow and
then for you were playing against the
Reds when you got it I think they
scheduled the ceremony for that day for
that for that crossover dude that must
have been so crazy yeah I you go on for
10 years on my phone I had a picture of
a sa Young Award um I think it was I
don't remember exactly whose sa Young
Award it was I used to see the name
every day and then every time I opened
my phone that was the background picture
of my phone like every time I was
looking at it I just would see it in my
mind and then I replaced that picture
with now the background on my phone is
my sa Young Award um because I want
another one but yeah I chased it for 10
years and finally like finally
accomplished it which is a a pretty
crazy um to chase something for 10 years
uh and finally get it is like such a
cool feeling I didn't even know like how
to feel it was like I can't believe this
actually
happened yeah are you able to feel proud
Pride like kind of well do
you not in not in the moment um and by
the time I win something I've already
like set the next Target yeah and I was
like I wanton it and I was like okay but
anyone can win one like wow you can't
win who who can how many guys have won
two how many have won three and like so
I just it's one of my struggles I need
to get better at it is like actually
enjoying the fact that I did this really
cool thing what a trickster your brain
is and cuz sometimes our brain is like a
trickster it's like oh well it's like
and what about this you know it's like
sometimes if I can look at that
almost like yeah and try and enjoy it
not be too hard on myself not you know
constantly be pushing the goal line but
sometimes if I can just look at myself
and be like what a trickster you
are brain you're gonna go and make
you're gonna we just did it you're yeah
like let me let me like hang out here
for a little bit I enjoy this but if I
can at least laugh at that part of me
that does it instead of look at it like
man it just keeps moving and I'm never
able to have any fun that can help me
have a little bit of a different like
space there like I get like uh long-term
enjoyment out of it like little little
hits of it here and there so the award
is actually up in my room at my parents
house like where I grew up and I this is
where I you I still have artwork that I
made in high school that's on the walls
and like hats that I had signed by
people that are hanging there like it's
it's like my room um and so the award is
like hang hanging up like in my
childhood room um because I feel like
that's where it belong like most people
put it in like a case and like that's
where the journey started got it and
like that's where it I feel like it just
belongs
like the young kid that like never
thought he'd play Big League Baseball
because big league baseball players are
they're Superstars they're like
different than me and all of a sudden I
end up being of those people and have
this thing that like only the best of
the best get and it's like still when I
see it up there I'm like this is crazy
like yeah I have a note from my high
school coach threatening to kick me off
the team next to like the sa Young Award
like the the the the disparity between
those things is like such a such an
interesting contrast you know bro it's
that oh that's so many feelings that's
so much at once dude what was what was
he threatening to kick you off for do
you remember dude I
was I have like four or five of them uh
I got thrown out of a game one time I
was hitting and uh umpire made a b what
I thought was a bad call so I flipped my
bat and I like drew a line in the sand
of like where the ball acrossed the
plate didn't say a word I got tossed and
then of course like you're getting
thrown out of a game not good look for
the high school program there's times
where like the park that I mentioned
earlier where i' go up and do practice
like I would go up there and throw B
there's a tennis court with like a
really high fence next to a big open
grass field and so I would throw long
toss on the open grass field and the
ball would hit the fence and like there
and I had to throw by myself so I'd have
two buckets of balls and I would throw
them all and then go pick them up and
keep throwing and then one of the local
tennis instructors didn't like the noise
of the ball hitting the fence and so he
would go and like we had this years long
like Feud and he would come out in the
middle of his tennis lessons and like
grab my buckets of baseballs and steal
them so I couldn't throw and then he
would like call the cops on me and like
all this stuff but the thing is there
was no signs it's public park no signs
on the fence saying that I couldn't
throw against it we'd gone to city
council and like cleared it and made
sure it was okay he just didn't like it
so a lot
of lot of just technical back and forth
yeah but you like to make sure that you
you're kind of like me I think it seems
in some ways I think I like I always
wanted to make sure how I felt was known
I always wanted to have my say in things
so or be able to have my say that's what
I felt like and it's sometimes it's a
blessing and sometimes it's a curse for
sure um I
had I had I I remember the the morning
um that that kind of like changed for me
I was 17 was in high school I had gotten
up in the morning to go to the YMCA did
my pre preschool workout came back
showered was looking in the mirror I was
like you know why what what is it about
me that like I don't have friends that
people like like don't like me that they
bully me that they pick on me like all
this stuff and I just made the decision
that day I was like I like myself like
I'm good in school I treat people well
I'm hardworking I'm whatever like I like
what I see looking back at me so I'm
going to be okay with that and I'm not g
to I'm going to stop chasing like
approval from other people and as long
as I can be proud of myself like I'm
cool with it and so that gave me the
freedom internally to like have a voice
and when someone would say something to
me I'd fire back and I would feel better
about myself because I felt like I was
defending myself and standing up for
myself and my life got a lot
better uh through the rest of high
school and into college because of that
because I felt like I had a voice and I
was being heard instead of just being
like swatted down all the time and then
as my life situation changed you know
something that can be good at one point
can be bad at other points um as my life
situation changed as people stopped
picking on me as much as you I got into
professional baseball and my profile in
baseball grew I was still very quick to
just like fire back at people and you
know fans normally in like the Bantry
like good-natured way but media people
you know uh onair personalities writers
and stuff like that um they would write
something about me that I didn't like or
that I disagreed with or I felt was UN
true that's one thing that really bugs
me is when someone writes something that
is not true about about anyone like I
don't think you should because it
affects the person's uh reputation and
stuff you know um so I would just fire
back at them and I was like okay I'm
justifying this to myself because they
attacked me first and they said this
stuff that isn't true they set the terms
where they're going to just come out of
they're going to go out of their way to
like I wouldn't pick on them they're
going to come after me well okay unleash
it like fire back yeah I think makes
good sense yeah I would just unload on
on people though like said some pretty
hurt ful things and then you know I get
the reputation of being this like
combative person which I'm not but
that's how I appeared on online and I
don't think I updated
my like how
I uh behaved and interpreted the world
like I don't think I updated that as
quickly as like my life situation
changed I see and so I got to a point
where like I didn't need to be doing
that stuff and there's a much more
mature way to handle those things like
just have a conversation with a person
instead of just like online like firing
back um so that's one thing over the
last couple years I've really tried to
like update evolve in update my my how I
perceived the world like how I operate
in the world to match like my life
situation well sometimes it makes sense
that that takes like um sometimes the
world doesn't take into account that we
have to get to certain places where we
have enough space to look around at our
environment
and update our own software right and
and and sometimes it takes time it's
like and and that's just what it is you
know but um the media is also gross I
want to I'll say that you don't have to
say that and um uh I think the media is
very gross these days there's countless
things that are printed all the time and
said that have no
uh jurist Prudence is that a word Nick
why am I saying
that sounds right jurist Prudence I
don't know what oh it just means a legal
system oh yeah yeah I just I don't know
no merit I don't know I think I remember
just reading uh Scarlet Letter and that
popped into my head for some reason but
I'm forever stuck on whatever books I
read in like ninth grade bro
forever dude people like you you have a
good vocabulary I'm like dude if it
wasn't in uh The Scarlet Letter
dude I don't know it um but no it's
interesting man and especially I think
learning more about you you see like oh
well this is this guy has had to kind of
like create his own operating software
to fit what's works with him in his
world you know and that's um a lot of
people you don't get to know that about
him you know um I think Society there
should be
more uh the way Society is right now is
everything's like very short attention
span and very final yeah it is this or
it is that and then that's true for the
rest of time um where in reality it's
like this might have been the case at
this specific moment in time with these
circumstances this person feeling one
way on that day because of this other
thing this other person feeling this
other way on and then like that
situation changes so the people change
the next day the next week the next year
but you look at you look back at
something someone said five years ago
and you're like oh well he's a terrible
person because of this or oh I love him
because of this one thing when like it's
a tiny snapshot of a brief moment that
doesn't describe
the whole of the situation the person
the intent the anything but Society I
think is like so short with forming an
opinion well especially with athletes
you only get to see certain amounts of
them yeah like um and when they go on a
lot of long form conversations a lot of
times they um there's someone you know
there's a lot of fear about you know
saying certain they don't want to say
too you know they don't want to get in
trouble you only see certain like uh
snapshots of them on the Seline you see
a guy get upset two times yeah you have
no idea what's happened or what's going
on but suddenly you're like oh that
guy's the problem dude I saw the best
example of that um it's NBA game I think
it was Durant it might have been someone
else but um I'm just gonna say it was
Durant because I that's what that's
what's in my head but he's doing an
interview right on the court right after
the game right and the reporter asked
him a question he's got a microphone in
his face oh yeah the team this and that
and the other whatever and he's got this
like polished like you can tell like
it's
a he's been trained like how to talk to
the media like say words without saying
anything at all like not a whole don't
say anything at all basically but say
something so in the middle of one of his
answers one of his teammates or I think
someone from the other team comes up to
like hey good game and he steps away
from the microphone for like 3 seconds
and completely changes just like oh
what's up brother hey great is like
going into this whole thing with someone
that he's comfortable with in a
different way yeah and he comes back to
the interview right back into like the
media mode and I'm like if that's not
the perfect example of how like what you
see is not always what is true right um
I don't know what is yeah there's a
certain protecting of the realm in a lot
of ways you know which part of it makes
sense too especially I think with
baseball because baseball has this um I
have to pee so bad man is that okay sure
do you have to pee or you okay I'm good
wow that's amazing when people don't
have to pee to me um what um so
everything was going so your so your
career was going great yeah and then you
had this you had the instance that
happened with the uh allegations right
is that the best way to say it how do
people yeah I mean there's allegations
against me stuff I didn't do but dick
gets out in social media the media
writes about it and uh to be fair like
they were very serious allegations like
what was alleged was very you know
should be investigated and should be
taken very seriously um just you know
the way the system works it's like those
get those allegations get made there's
an open investigation you know I'm
advised not to say anything so it's only
it's a very one-sided discussion for a
long period of time right and then that
influences public perception over it and
then when the facts start coming out
when the truth starts coming out it's a
much smaller
uh there's there's a lot less Buzz
around it and so the public perception's
already been influenced in a certain way
it must have been harrowing to go
through yeah it
sucked it sucked um it still
sucks um
but um so and it doesn't even sound like
it was that CRA it sounds like there was
just you message with a woman online you
guys both agree to spend time together
you spend time together um it's later
revealed that she had the idea that she
wanted
to she had a plan or a strategy to
um did it say like
to take from you I'm trying to think
what the strategy was there's there was
yeah texts about you know taking my
money um gosh getting in yeah stuff like
that yeah next star picture for the
Dodgers um and what's so crazy is Trev
is I was like 3 months ago I'm looking
at some stuff online am I okay talking
with you about this do you feel okay for
sure all right um I'm looking at some
stuff online I see pictures of the girl
and I'm like how do I know this girl I
had she had connected with me over
social media at some point um and we met
up she came to a comedy show and then
she came afterwards we went to my hotel
we just sat in the lobby and chatted
yeah and uh she like knew some friend we
had some mutual friends and stuff and um
but we just sat there and chatted and
then I got her an Uber home yeah um
thank goodness I guess you know but but
that it just blew I'm like looking at
I'm like how do I but even that to me
cuz I knew she I felt like she wanted to
stay over and spend time you know it
just blew my mind I'm like is this is
this like a thing like was this person
like doing this kind of stuff regularly
or was it it just happen stance that you
know anyway it just that and that got me
even more into your world kind of and uh
and I really started to look back at
what had gone on and and man it was just
I think a lot of people felt like it was
just a really raw deal yeah I mean I
certainly feel that way um I can't
change it obviously at this point like
it it is what it is like the situation
happened
um I've had to
I I've had to do like two like two main
things one I've had to like self-reflect
okay how did I get into this situation
where like something like this is even
possible yeah and then two I've had to
look towards the future and try to have
something that I'm moving towards or
something that I'm trying to accomplish
because if I don't and I would just get
mired in this really negative stuff um
and that's you know it's not good for
mental Health it's not good for
productivity or the people that I'm
around or you know wow stuff like that
so I've done a lot of reflecting and
like looking at mistakes that I made
and
um a lot of like there's a lot of
components to this whole situation like
number one like my interactions
with uh females like in general like I
paid very little attention to my
personal life cuz I was so focused on
baseball and then when I started my
businesses it was baseball and business
and I just didn't pay attention to
anything else so I just like I didn't
think anything of it someone would hit
me up on Instagram and like oh
yeah you do whatever I I didn't think
anything of it and I think it at the
time it was like well I I treat people
well and I'm respectful and like I don't
I'm not doing anything improper and so
like that's fine I'm yeah that's a way
to live I'm living the way you're
supposed to be living yeah and it never
even crossed my mind that something like
this could happen um but you know I was
associating with people that were not
that didn't
see yeah people were like hitting me up
on Instagram because they knew me
somehow but I didn't know them you know
I would just meet up with them I knew
very little about them um that was
dangerous in my position part of like
what discussed about the software update
like I see myself as just this guy
that's like even with everybody else
that just you know and then I get into a
position in life where that's not the
case and I become a Target and I just
didn't see like the signs of being a
Target or whatever and so I didn't
update my software early enough and it's
a bummer yeah it's a bummer because you
also you want to be able to meet people
on even terms that's the toughest thing
about sometimes having some popularity I
think and something it's sometimes kind
of like I don't want to say sad because
nobody's like hey look man you get to
have a lot of neat do a lot of neat
things yeah I I don't ever want to come
off like a victim like it was like I was
treated no I don't think it sound way or
whatever it's just like there are
realities to the certain situations and
definitely very very positive like being
a professional athlete and like having
that opportunity like there's so many
positives to it um I don't ever want to
come off like I'm complaining yeah but
there are certain realities that go
along with it that you have to be
cognizant of and um yeah I just I didn't
update quick enough to be cognizant of
them before it happened I've updated now
like I've changed
a lot of how I do things in my personal
life like I'm very careful of who I meet
and how I meet them um you know I'm not
having the same type of just casual
sexual relationships and I'm not
agreeing to do the same types of like
sexual things um I'm not like dating a
bunch of people I've like really locked
down my personal life and gone back to
the to the square one like what do I
care about in a personal relationship
okay I want someone that's a b c d what
whatever okay let me go try to find
those things actively instead of just
being okay with anybody that's
approaching me just
to have someone around in those blank
moments where like oh I have two hours
at night and I have nothing to do so
like I'll just have someone I'll meet up
with somebody exactly yeah oh dude it's
saying look I can relate I'm not trying
to take your conversation here but just
young man can relate to that just the
same type of thing it's like and even
young women it's like it just becomes a
habitual thing yeah you know people
think they're you know but it's like
yeah sometimes the reason why maybe I
haven't landed exactly where I would
like to be um it's yeah it's like have I
if well I just if I just kind of take
whatever like shooting star passes
through the sky yeah as opposed to going
out and looking for like somebody that's
the real sunshine you know it's
like and not you might Clevenger but uh
like a preferably female but um but yeah
I feel you man it's like I can all day
because people just kind of come and go
all the time and that's fine you can do
that but if you really want to go out
and you and like emulate what you want
into the world and then hopefully get
that back you know yeah I think longterm
wise like it's just a much more
healthy uh situation for me personally
um to be surrounded by people that are
interested in the same things that push
me in a positive way to get better to
learn more
to achieve more whatever that support in
moments one of the biggest things is
like getting through the last couple
years I even today like it's still a
struggle today with you know there's
still ongoing like ramifications of
everything um but just having the
support group around you that like you
know these people care about you and not
the attributes that you like not the
bank account or the fame or the
notoriety or whatever the lifestyle like
having that support group you know
weeding out some of the people that were
around that like didn't feel that way
and really locking down the people that
you Vibe with and that like you know
have your back and are going to give you
some of those free spaces to mess up and
like as long as you learn and continue
getting better they're not just like
gone when one bad thing happens right
that's been so important um and I'm so
thankful for those people my family like
my business partner my agent Rachel like
there's a lot of other people friends I
can't name everybody of course but yeah
those people the support group that are
there it's so important yeah like when
hit the fan right was it like did
it kind of was it totally a shock to you
it was it was pretty bad yeah um I went
from focusing on my next start to then
like this article came out and then I'm
having all these conversations and then
I'm not allowed at the field and I'm
still going to pitch in two days but
then I'm not going to pitch in two days
and then I can't take the team flight
back uh because I'm not allowed to be
with the team right now and then I can't
take a commercial flight back home
because I'm my name's everywhere and
it's such a big story that like it's
going to be a disaster at you know
taking commercial flight to renting a
car and driving from DC like back across
the United States in the middle of
season not knowing when I'm going to
rejoin the like it was a who drove with
you um I drove with my agent Rachel oh
um yeah she was in DC and then we were
there for two or three days and then
drove back across country um yeah
it was it was uh it happened pretty
quick and then obviously like you have
the legal stuff that plays out you have
you know investigation and um you know
was never never arrested for anything
was never charged with anything there
was never any that drug out for
uh drug out is a wrong word because like
the allegations are serious and they
should have you know they looked into
them thoroughly and I respect the hell
out of the police for doing that like I
think all allegations like this should
be looked into with that amount of
thorough uh thoroughness yeah but it it
lasted for nine months before the
decision was made that there was going
to be no no charges whatever the whole
time I was like not able to be with a
team there was no resolution there's no
I didn't know when any of those
decisions were going to come out so I'm
just in this holding pattern and then
there was MLB suspended me and then
there was you know
we um appealed the suspension and then
that took another I don't even remember
how long that took another period of
time um things move slowly in the you
know as they go through courts and as
they go through uh unb arbitrations and
stuff like that so and who was there who
was like really there for you while you
like yeah um parents have been parents
have been great
um uh Rachel I've mentioned um she was
there business partner Tosh uh a lot of
my uh employees that I consider close
friends Kevin Eric um you know we've
hired more people along the way as well
that have been like there um whole time
um yeah friends I mean there's people
that I just know that for you know since
school or whatever that like would check
in with me coaches um I don't want to
name names because I don't whatever but
a lot of coaches and and that I've known
through baseball a lot of players
teammates you had some good support yeah
um and I think it's because people that
I've played with people that I've been
in the clubhouse with people that I've
known personally looked at their
experience with who I am and what they
know of me and like what's being said
and they just just like nope there's no
way that there's no way that happened
and um yeah so I think you know publicly
it's been seen as like I'm this you know
there's reports that I you know Dodgers
organization doesn't want me around and
teammates don't this and I'm not welcome
here and all that stuff but like what's
been seen publicly and my experience of
what's been going on kind of behind the
scenes and and my interactions with
people and stuff like that have been
completely different wow um so it's
actually been it's been good like
knowing
that you know the the people that I know
that have been around me have
that uh amount of I guess trust or that
have had a good experience with me and
like believe yeah I saw mie best said
some nice things there was in that um or
that that's what they they put out in
the Articles you just don't know with a
lot of these articles man and the
lawyers too that's the shadiest part
sometimes is like um it seemed like in
your since the
lawyers uh use the media to make you
look worse
yeah that's crazy exactly that's
like why wouldn't you just do what the
rule like it just man that made
me it just was sick it was sickening I
don't know enough about the legal system
to Warrant having an opinion so I don't
want this to come off as like I am
advocating for one thing or another but
it seems like there's this Loop poll
having been through it where like you
can make a domestic violence uh
restraining order request you can file
for for one of those and you can write a
whole bunch of stuff and that's fine
because you have to be able to write
what happened and make your claim and
then that is
filed that becomes a public document you
don't have to attach your name to it but
you can attach the other person's name
to it wow and then it takes time for
that to go through to get scheduled to
get heard to get decided
upon but the damage in today's society
is already been done as soon as that
becomes
public that like you know we we went to
the domestic violence restraining order
Court which is like the lowest standard
of proof that you have to to in order to
get that to to win a a domestic violence
restraining order like it's the lowest
standard ofof we went to that and won
like there was no restraining order
granted but in the month or I think it
was actually like a month I think it was
like 6 weeks in between when the initial
filing and articles came out and when
that happened that's six weeks of one
side of the story being out there and
like damage is done I can't you not to
say anything yeah and I've had great
legal representation and they've advised
me well along the way and the advice is
don't say anything and it kills me
because like I want to defend myself I
want to get the truth out there and then
it's like okay well what is the what's
the reparation for the damage that's
been done here and it doesn't seem like
there's any sort of yeah yeah and Fu
maybe there's maybe there's some sort of
update that can be made to the to that
process like I also see the other side
of it where you know for people that are
in those situations that need a place to
be able to go and like get help and to
get out of a bad situation and to
protect themselves like we never want to
discourage that from happening either so
I don't know what the solution is here
but just like
having talked to people in professional
sports and like a lot of people have
reached out and like hey man I went
through something similar this is what
they did to me or this is what happened
in my case or this what was seemingly
was helpful or whatever like this is a
thing that happens a lot again for I
don't I just know what happened with me
just from what I've been told right this
is your instance yeah it's um you know
the the general way is like you make
these allegations and then tell the
person you're going to file this thing
and in order and they you know the
implications it's going to be very bad
for you and so then money exchanges
hands and I've talked to multiple people
where that's been the case right so it's
just like uh people can do that and
threat make and then you have to pay to
get rid of it yeah yeah yeah you know I
don't know how they update and it's
tough that they don't have to attach
their name to it because then there's no
real repercussions for them you know
yeah um I'm sorry you had to go through
that man yeah you know I know that
doesn't help or anything but I think a
lot of people probably feel that way we
all have our struggles and I don't like
I'm very fortunate to be in the position
I am even with all this stuff like I'm
not blind to that and so again I don't
want to I never want to come off as like
oh wo is me and like I was victim here
or anything like that I mean I believe
that you were a victim there and I'll
just say that for myself but um I don't
think you sound like that at all yeah um
it was a tough situation we all have
tough situations in life and like
hopefully something that I say about how
I got through it or how I am trying to
like learn from past mistakes and be
better is helpful to the next person
yeah that that goes through it so it
makes their time a little bit easier
than my time was that's it's thoughtful
of you it's kind of a powerful to get to
that place I'm sure it's been an
interesting Journey you
know it's been interesting I think in
like 10 years when I look back on it
I'll be um I think there'll be a lot of
things in my life that have
happened because of changes that I made
during this time period that I'll be
very happy with yeah um it's just very
hard to like see off into the future
when you're so in it and when you feel
like you know you're what everything you
knew about your world is completely like
gone like you're basically just torn
down to zero like where do I go from
here what am I
doing um but as far as like updating the
software and stuff I think I'll be happy
in in five or 10 years that like changes
that I've made because of this
experience um have helped me like grow
as a person you know dude you're
in it's a it is a high road
attitude um to hear from you for me like
I can't I can't go any other road
because it'll just it's poisonous yeah
um yeah so what's next then what's next
how do we get to see you cuz I want to
see you go for that second side young
I'm going to be really really honest
with you yeah I'd love to I mean that's
the goal like I'd like to play uh in MLB
um you know looking for looking for a
contract
and um yeah I mean I still I've been
training the whole time like we talked
earlier about how baseball's like my
backdrop like when things go bad I go
back to this and this has been one of
the most difficult things is like when
baseball's taken away like what do I
fall back on so I just fell back on
training so I'm in you know I I I've
improved like since last people last saw
me like I I'm throwing harder I've
developed new pitches my command's
better I'm still one of the best
pitchers in the world um I'd love to
prove that obviously I realize there's a
lot of uh you know other considerations
besides just Talent um at this point so
I'm hopeful that I get a job and I get
an opportunity to go out and and prove
that I'm good and I have a lot to offer
I think I got lot to offer the baseball
Community as a whole with content
entertainment and and all that I have a
lot to offer a team like one of the
things I'm really passionate about is
helping young baseball players have
their journey be easier than mine so we
actually train I think we got like 20
guys that we train for free at my
facility in in Arizona in the offseason
Pro guys that come in uh I've been
working with all the pitchers there and
developing pitches and feel and mindset
and all that stuff I love that stuff so
I have a lot to offer from that
perspective I think to a team and a
clubhouse that I'm with um obviously
like performance like you got to win
games I know I can do that that's not
even a question in my mind so what was
like the financial cuz you were making
good money yeah right yeah I signed um
so I won the sa young 2020 and then that
was your contract year I was a free
agent after that yeah wow bro that is a
dream and look I love it when dudes get
paid what George KD told me he goes
everybody's happy when somebody gets
paid man yeah for sure so you had three
years 102 million yeah so that it was a
kind of a unique structure the plan I
had opt outs after every year the plan
was always to the first play the first
two years and then opt out and be a free
agent after the third and I would have
been two years for 85 million the way
the contract worked out so an average
value of 42 and a. half million a year
wow um which was the highest annual
average value at that time for any
baseball player I think sh just crushed
no way so you were like the top of the
heat yeah wow and did they still have to
pay you a certain amount of that yeah um
I got some of it I also lost some of it
in the you know I think
um I don't remember exactly what the
numbers shook out to be but I lost a
significant amount of it with the
suspension and stuff like that so and
was it expensive like the law attorney
fees and all that yeah man lawyers are
uh very much needed like very special Iz
and like you know you need you need them
but um very expensive yeah so it's
been um obviously baseball's giving me a
lot financially um I'm doing fine I
don't want to come off like I'm you know
not fine but uh it's been a heavy a
heavy hit for sure um and how do your
agents like do you try to go back at the
same rate like how does that even work
is that fair to ask you about to ask you
about yeah yeah that's fine um I don't
like I just want to play like that's
that's where I'm at um like I I'll play
for league minimum and like earn my
money based in incentives like I I don't
care whatever whatever the structure for
the team is like that makes them most
comfortable like I it's fine with me I
just want to go play yeah you know yeah
incentive based right yeah you want to
you I'll show you if yeah if you sign me
and like something's not going right and
you don't like the reaction or you don't
whatever like you can cut me and then
you don't have to bear the um you know
the brunt of signing this let's say it's
a $10 million contract and you know
something's not going right and you
still have to pay the 10 million I don't
I don't need that like I just want to I
want a job I want to go play and like
let me just prove that I'm still one of
the best pitchers let me prove that I
have a lot to offer the organization
yeah and then I'll get paid in
incentives I'll earn based on what I
perform I'm happy with that um I've
never like I've always wanted to be that
way too like it's I've I've only wanted
to sign one-year contracts because I
never want to be the guy that signs a
long-term deal and then is like okay
well I'm getting paid regardless so
performance doesn't matter and I'm just
going to like play out my years or
whatever I'm just going to get massages
or whatever paint my nails or whatever
yeah like shout out to the guys that
paint their nails no problem with it but
like yeah no judgment yeah but uh like I
I'm an intense competitor and I just
want to go compete and like I would like
to be compensated fairly for what I
produce so if I produce nothing I don't
feel like I should be compensated
anything if I'm the best pitcher in the
league I feel like I should be
compensated for being the best pitcher
in the league and the easiest way to do
that is just like minimum risk for the
team I'll play for the minimum and then
if I pitch really well then have
incentives that reward me for pitching
really well and the value that I give to
the team is equally shared and both
sides feel like they won um wow I'm I'm
happy to have any sort of
like like yeah I want to work together
with the team I want to be a positive in
the community in the clubhouse on the
field like overall for the game of
baseball um I know that I can be that I
have no questions about it which is why
I have no problem taking like a
incentive based contract because I know
that I can go out there and deliver um I
know the type of person that I am I know
the type of results that I'm be able to
produce and I'm willing to bet on myself
in that way but at the at the end of the
day like I just I just want to compete
like I just want a chance to go compete
and like do the thing that I've spent 30
years becoming one of the best in the
world at and the thing that I love to do
um bro I would if I had a team if I had
even if we had a spot here I'd hire you
right now I'd hire you to pit what would
you what would you call it what what
your what your team name be oh that's a
great question huh put you on the
spot what's a good team name probably
maybe uh the Reverb or the lisps the
lisps yeah one of my best friends
growing up Douglas had a lisp and I
would always um I would impersonate him
because I was in it was like the he had
the unique voice and one of the teachers
one time thought I was making fun of him
I'm like what do you mean I'm not he's
like he God put that remix in him like
he's doing something different like I
just thought it was so cool you know so
the lists could be kind of cool cuz it's
like taking something that can be
considered kind of like maybe not the
best but making it positive you that
could be pretty dope what else the
Nashville lisps o dude it's got a ring
yeah might be the list dude yeah
thri I sounded like hoe Mandell saying
that joke um but dude well if we could
if we could afford you even at basic
mene we'd pay you a pitch here but we
don't have a team we don't have we don't
have a field
but God dude that yeah we just got to
see you back out there there's no valid
reason why you shouldn't be back out
there yeah I appreciate you saying that
like I there's no valid it doesn't even
make nothing if the universe doesn't
make this happen it doesn't even make
any sense anymore yeah yeah I uh I'm
hopeful that it will I'm hopeful it will
I I just I would like to entertain
people i' like to to pitch I'd like to
win when does spring training start uh
usually like second week around
Valentine's Day second week of February
some teams are like February 12th some
teams are like February 16th it's like
they all kind of report at different
dates but yeah middle of February bro
date with the diamond huh yeah and
that's not Dustin pory I'm talking about
uh baseball diamond yeah yeah we could
see it bro yeah just looking for an
opportunity uh I want to play an MLB I
love Japan I I have absolutely nothing
negative to say about Japan um and at
some point like being separated from the
culture that I'm comfortable with and
I'm used to to like it was tough and
being away from friends and family and
stuff like that everyone made everyone
there made it so much better than it
could have been and I'm very
appreciative but yeah I would like I
would like to play an MLB I would like
to chase the second sa young I'd like to
you know try to win a World Series I
finished second you know oh yeah you
guys came in second place with the
Dodgers uh no with uh with Cleveland in
2016 and I finished second in college uh
we lost to TCU in the national champion
or not TCU to South Carolina in National
Championship so I finished I finished
second twice I'd like to actually win
one wow um but yeah yeah dude it would
be so cool what if you got to play with
the Padres but if you got to play with
the Dodgers Walker buer plays over there
D they just went and signed uh uh sh and
Yamamoto too oh that's right I talked to
I talked to Yamamoto when I was in Japan
uh through an interpreter like he's he's
a he's a pretty special pitcher I'm
excited to see how he does um would love
to would love to play there sh's a
pitcher of there too right sh showy
Yamamoto ber uh Kershaw is a free agent
still I don't know if he's going to sign
but I'm not sure his spine's going to
hold it pieced but I mean he's he's
pieced up in the spine he's amazing yeah
but he's just yeah he's like uh you got
a massage that yeah you got to get him
into that wagu shape you because he's
just you know his body's turn so much
he's got so much so many innings under
his belt it's such a high level that
like no one's body can take it for
forever right um but I mean even so with
all the with all the years and the
mileage like he put up a fantastic
season last year it's incredible seeing
what he's the longevity he's had and
like the consistency of results just
like it's crazy and their head coach
who's the Dodgers head coach Dave
Roberts yeah dude that guy's cool man
bring up a picture of Dave Roberts dude
UCLA yeah bro oh do you play with him at
UCL too I didn't play with him but he
was a he's a brewing yeah wow dude yeah
he's cool man
he's funny yeah they got some funny guys
over there it's a cool organization it
it would be cool to it' be cool to play
you I'd obviously love to to play for
them it'd be cool to play against them
too because of the the big like they
just went and spent like 1.2 billion
dollars in free agency yeah like okay
this is the Juggernaut like let's go see
if we can take him down type of thing so
I could get up for either one of them
you
know mainly like I just I just want to I
want to play man I haven't
I I miss competing I'm yeah was it tough
to was there certain parts of the Season
that are tougher to watch like when it
gets in the playoffs or it's all just
kind of tough it's been tough to watch
baseball um because like I know I'm good
enough to be out there and I I want to
be out there and I haven't I haven't had
the opportunity to to be out there um
when I was in Japan last year I watched
a lot of games because I was like okay
I'm I'm here I'm playing I'm like in it
I can respect what the other people are
doing I can learn from it I'm like
figuring things out and that was nice to
have some of that back where I just
haven't I don't think it's been healthy
for me to like consume MLB content the
last couple years um which is sad
because like everything that I've tried
to build is like grow that entity and
like help build it and then um I'm still
involved in in doing that I'm still but
I'm just pursuing it a slightly
different way where I'm not even like
I'm not really watching games and
um I'd like to get back to a place where
like I can like watch and like be
interested in like appreciate the great
things that other people in the league
are doing I just had to like be a little
bit protective of my of my uh Mental
Health on on that front but yeah because
would it just kind of it would just
break your heart probably yeah it was
tough man like seeing what other guys
are doing and not being able to be happy
for them feeling that resentment of like
well I should be out there being able to
compete too God um I don't like I
never I don't you should have been
there's no reason yeah I can't even
imagine I don't like being negative
towards other people and like feeling
envious of other people's
accomplishments I like to look at things
and be like wow this person is really
really good and I can appreciate it
because I do it in all other sports like
I watch Brady play and I'm like I'm
going to watch as much of this as
possible because he's going to be gone
at some point and like you got to appre
apprciate what's what this is yeah same
with
s yeah um and and momes right now I do
that with and Kaylin Clark I want me and
Caleb Presley want to come to your um
game at again uh so if we if you can
help us sorry I just had to say that out
loud dude love it m Pete that's what I
call it she's a I love watching her yeah
um but yeah man yeah it's I think
because if you if there was no there was
no criminal wrong there was nothing
wrong yeah there was nothing wrong yeah
um you can find things that if you look
at yourself yes I could adjust some of
these behaviors and stuff but as a human
being behaving in the world to not have
done anything wrong yeah and to have
it's really just a trial that you've
been through it's almost like a
Scarlet Letter you know it was like a
Scarlet Letter in a way you know yeah
you get branded with something and then
you carry it I'll carry it the rest of
my life like I'll always be known for
this in some way and hopefully over time
it'll be less and I'll the positive
things that I do will get more attention
and be more synonymous with my brand but
like this will always be there um which
is which is tough it's tough to I can't
even imagine I can't think about it too
much you know yeah yeah because it's
just such a it's such an anomaly yeah
you know um yeah so we got to get you we
gota we don't have to do anything I
can't do but it'd be awesome yeah
dude this come just like the I would
love to see you get to play with the
Padres too dude they got Benny Snell
over there don't they uh he's a free
agent right now I think they got darish
darish I love I love Musgrove yeah um
they got a great team yeah and they just
got a new head coach on football too who
was it they got uh who the har the
Chargers got Harbaugh yeah from Michigan
they got har he might come out to a game
that would be cool go Blue got some I
got some friends that are big Michigan
fans so yeah oh they were all those
people were so geeked
recently they had a crazy season all the
adversity they went through as a team
like it's crazy when you watch that and
you're like okay like adversity either
tears you apart or makes you so much
stronger like they really came together
and they put a they put together a hell
of a run what do you say like what do
you what are your thoughts cuz you're
almost relatable to like I mean it's
very scary like any somebody being like
in any sort of like
a public Persona or something or
popularity it's very scary right um man
God it's just but there's probably guys
who are imprisoned right now for things
that they didn't do for sure like and
that's I try to keep that perspective
and
like yeah I'm noty this has sucked I'm
not trying to belittle what you went
through it could be way worse what what
but you're a person who was able to set
goals and set and really get through
like some of the tougher parts of Life
by your
own manifestations
and game planning yeah right it seems
like in your life how do you like what
did you
do and because I'm sure there are guys
sitting in a Cell right now who can
might be able to learn some stuff yeah I
think one of the biggest things is
talking about it and that was one of the
toughest things I couldn't talk about it
publicly so having a having some someone
privately that you could just talk to
about it to at least hear yourself
vocalize what you're feeling like I if I
didn't have someone to talk to I would
not have I would not have made it
through this um that's a huge thing like
it's scary to talk about things a lot of
times and like be viewed as vulnerable
or to be viewed you know you don't know
how the other person's going to view
your perspective but it's so important
uh so I'd say first thing like find
someone to talk to whether it's a
therapist whether it's a friend a family
member you know a lot of people aren't
fortunate enough to have family members
around to talk to or they don't have
those relationships but find someone
that you can talk to um and be honest
with yeah like be able to just tell it
how you're feeling it yeah be honest
about you how you're feeling yes um
that's that's the biggest thing I'd say
and then having something some goal like
humans need a purpose like we don't do
well when we're like just existing for
and we don't have anything to do and if
you can find some purpose that's
controllable that like you know for me
it was business like I had a business so
I woke up in the morning I'm like okay
how do we get this thing firing or how
do we get uh make a better video or how
do we edit this way or okay I got to
figure out the you know what higher do
we need to make so there was something
that I was in control of that I was
actively doing that I could distract
myself in a way from the negative stuff
and like focus on something that was
like aspirational like okay in the
future when all this stuff is done
because it's going to be done at some
point it may be a day it might be a year
it might be 10 years it's not going to
last forever so at some point in the
future when it's done what is it that I
have that I've been building that I can
like Aspire what position do I want to
be when this is done like and can I make
progress towards that like that's how I
is like talking about it and having some
sort of aspirational goal that I was
chasing um but yeah like the support
group is is so big man yeah like just
being able to vocalize your feelings is
important yeah oh yeah yeah I'm in a lot
of support groups dude yeah I mean
fortunately and unfortunately but some
of those moments are the best moments of
my life you know dealing with addiction
and learning about recovery and stuff um
it's given me some of the greatest Gifts
of my life which are great conversations
with people and learning how to be
around people and and feel and have and
and stuff like that I think the humans
learn by failing first and then
adjusting behavior and then growing and
it's a sense of Pride to be able to feel
like you've gotten better at something
or you're a in a better place or a
better person because of something
but the moments where you're failing
you're when you're in that like those
are tough but being able to have that
comeback is so important because that's
where you
feel that sense of accomplishment or
that sense of purpose or that you know
whatever it is you get something from
that if you never fail at anything like
life's just like there there's no
richness to it yeah you know um so I can
defin I can understand how some of those
moments like you fail at something you
end up in a bad place and you find a way
to like pull yourself back up and it
like feels a sense of Pride right yeah
yeah man it's interesting how much you
work with your own integrity and your
own like setting goals for yourself and
it must be it seem like you have
probably a knowledge of yourself on a
unique level that that some people don't
get to have man and I think that's I
think being an introvert like I don't I
don't do well in the social situations
like we talked about so I spend a lot of
time thinking
and a lot of it's about external stuff
but I try to think internally too
and um try to figure out why a lot of
time like okay I did this thing like why
did I do that what prompted me to react
this way emotionally to this situation
or what prompted me to go want to do
like why do I like cars or what what is
it right yeah and I'm trying to figure
out that puzzle because I'm a puzzle
yeah you're the puzzle and you're the
guy doing the puzzle that's what's kind
of cool once you realize that CU it can
make your life kind of richer in a way
yeah when you start to like not only am
I me but I'm
also um I can look at me yeah yeah and
it's a challenge because like you want
to look at
yourself like very surface level like oh
yeah I'm good like I look good today I'm
in good shape like oh things are good
but when you start like digging
down like maybe I'm not good in this
area like how could it be better or like
I don't know if I like this part about
me is it bad is it good I don't know
know like how do I actually feel about
this maybe I want to like try to do this
a little bit better like those are those
are conversations I have with myself all
the time like interesting dude
bro you a strange dude I dig it though I
dick it man I'm aware that I'm a
little different and I mean that
lovingly bro yeah I appreciate I really
read that respectfully we got to order
us a Trevor bow um bobblehead dude we
got to get one in here on the Shelf man
we want to dude I got I got some sitting
somewhere yeah yeah we're going to make
sure to hit up your um Rachel and make
sure she sends us over one even if she
has to drive it across country to get it
here we want it over here um we just
want to yeah we want to yeah man we just
yeah I got some uh I think I have a
couple unreleased bobbleheads that uh so
I I was supposed to have a bobblehead
day with the Dodgers um and so they had
sent me some samples as we were like
designing it and then I got put on
administrative leave before it happened
and so they never ended up like
releasing the bobbleheads wow but they
had ordered like some stock cuz they
were going to do an in inst stadium
giveaway so I got my hands on a couple
of those that never actually been
released which uh I think will be a cool
cool collector item so if you happen to
have one you want to part with or even
let us host in here for a while yeah
we're also willing to get one that has a
blank Jersey on and when you get your
new deal all right we're happy to uh to
get um to put that one Ino let me let me
see I got I got I got something for you
guys I just got a I haven't looked at
the inventory in a in a couple years but
I got something that'd be sweet man um
yeah dude yeah bro I wonder yeah dude
there's so many team how many teams are
there you could play for so many teams
yeah we got 30 30 teams out there um bro
some of them are bad dude they need you
I'm not I mean some of these teams are
ding bad or they could be doing they
could you could maybe help yeah I think
I could I mean I don't think there's a
team out there that I wouldn't help in
some way right um
but I also you know seeing the other
side of things like there's a lot of uh
you know potential uh distractions PR
concerns um I don't think they're I
don't think they would be as much as
people think they would be I think it'd
be like a couple days story and then
it'd be gone personally I I could be
wrong but um you think there would be
some Publications out there that would
feel like hey the best the least a way
that we could be supportive after you
know maybe lead the charge with not
being as supportive trying to even the
score you know yeah but I don't know
that's my thoughts yeah I mean it'd be
nice of course but um I'm not
gonna it's out of your control yeah if
it happens it happens like mooki coming
out and saying some stuff publicly was
like a I would never ask him to do that
but it
so like it meant a lot to me M's my guy
I love that guy yeah dude he built a
house in Nashville yeah that's what I
heard anyway somebody somebody might Li
but I text him the other day he's like
I'm like what have you been up to Moo
he's like ah just out here bowling man
he likes to bowl I was like yeah he dude
he's a he like bowls 300s he like bowls
professionally in the offseason God some
people get all the luck dude yeah have
you seen like he's he like he can dunk
he's like good basketball player great
baseball player bowler I'm like I think
he golfs like oh my god dude he's just
like he's one of those guys that just
like you put him in anything athletic
and he's just going to be one of the
best guys look at that wow look at him
look at him he's got the walk he's got
the SL he really does go back and look
at that walk look at mie Bing on this
strut this bro you see that little fist
pump before before the like it's that
Curry like he knows when he let it go
that that's the one it's just built into
him it's built into him yeah dude he's
got it's a little bit of Tiger Woods
esque too almost kind of hey the fist
pump right there you could probably
overlay those and be that's did you guys
ever like have some games like uh is
mooki a card player would you guys do
stuff like uh D we had this debate one
day if you took the Dodgers position
players and they had to pitch and the
Dodgers pitchers and they had to hit who
would win this should be a spring
training thing dude it should be always
thinking about this kind of stuff I was
I was like poking at him a little bit
I'm like dude we would dominate you guys
for sure you throw like 72 he's like
well you guys wouldn't be able to play
defense if we got one hit and we had
this like 40 45 minute discussion in the
clubhouse it was just like back and like
half the clubhouse was involved in it
it's like big argument it was great I I
hope at some point we get to we get to
test that out because it'd be a it'd be
fantastic content dude you're right yeah
it's a great idea man uh I like the way
you think man I really do and I I just
I'm grateful to get to spend time with
you today man and um and we wish you the
best of luck man we're going to get that
bble hit in here and uh and we'll be
we'll be cheering you on bro I
appreciate that thanks for having me on
it's been great yeah that second S Young
baby that's right get in there Trevor
Bower guys thank you
[Music]
Trevor like these leaves I must be
Cornerstone oh but when I reach that
ground I'll share this piece of mind I
found I can feel it in my
[Music]
bones